Ladies and gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link that says fleshlight and during
the code name Brogan,
you get 15% off.
All right,
and would that said Taka love bitches?
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
That black guy voice makes me uncomfortable,
dude.
I want to be honest with you.
There's a sound really a black guy voice.
It's a white guy talking like a black guy,
which has never cool,
which is not even right.
It's actually a robot that's been programmed to be a black guy,
holds a robot that's white made by white people.
They don't know how to do a black voice.
I liked Keira Knightley better.
Keira Knightley was better.
That was so hot.
There's something about,
uh,
someone,
a black guy faking a white voice is really completely acceptable to the best
black voice.
Yeah,
Gold Dude.
What does it,
does it weird you out though when you can call somebody on the phone,
you know that they're black when you're talking to them?
I like.
How would I describe this to an alien?
You know,
how would I describe how I saw this as a black guy,
but I know it's a black guy.
I miss that laugh.
Laugh brought to you by Bert pricer.
Ladies and Gentlemen Follow Bert on Twitter from K,
r e I.
S.
C h,
e r also known as birth to conquer on the travel channel,
which just started,
right?
Yup.
Last week was our first episode.
First week powerful.
Yeah,
and it was a raging success.
Great Ratings and Greg Social Media Success,
social media successors is a brand new thing they track on trend TV or TV.
Trenders and my agent sent it to me.
He's like you calling card and I was like,
I did and he was like,
you were number nine right behind the Kardashians.
Well right behind the fucking night.
It's just me.
It's me.
I literally,
here's my theory about promotion on Twitter.
I think you have to promote with a joke and that's my rule.
If you obsessive Li like,
like,
like I told you the other day,
Ralph,
he is just taking Twitter to a brand new level.
Thank you Brian.
Joe Hasn't seen any of it.
I'm like,
have you dodged that bullet coming out of Iraqi go?
They've been bombing in here.
I'm like,
it is like a wet Ralphie may is up to you.
I guarantee you he tweeted last two minutes,
I guarantee.
Yeah,
I just added them in and already he's been Kevin Smith and me.
but people who don't know is it Ralphie underscore may,
uh,
I don't know if it's him in that big orange jacket.
Yeah.
Ralph,
you underscore May.
It's um,
whoa.
Jesus Christ.
He's been on Twitter for how long?
Like a week?
Literally.
Literally a week.
Maybe a week and a half and an and he had like 15 tweets or like 20 tweets up
until then.
And I'm sure there's a thousand now.
How many total clinic?
The tweets he has because for some reason my,
my computer has gone back to the old Twitter.
You know I was using the new Twitter,
you know the,
the new Twitter science.
I don't know how to,
how to switch it up and had that very top.
Does it?
Is it [inaudible] underscore?
May Ralphie underscore Matt here.
I'll just go into my trend and I'll find them right away.
I don't know what happened.
All right.
He's got a total of what that can't be right.
He just started using it 1082 tweets.
It has all been using it a couple of weeks.
That's true.
True.
Yeah,
that's true.
Unless he's got some kind of
defense and Ralphie's defense,
he's not promoting anything.
He simply arguing.
He hasn't learned not to argue with people yet,
so he's,
he's just going back and forth and you really have to learn.
You have to learn that shit.
Yeah.
I just,
I never replied to anyone at all and I promote,
I only promote with a joke,
so if I'm going to promote the show,
I'll do something funny to promote it.
I think those get retweeted.
I try to be.
I don't,
not always funny if I find some interesting shit,
I just throw up some interesting shit.
Anything,
uh,
anything that I think is fascinating,
whether it's funny or not.
And if I have to promote something,
I promote something.
But I always tried to treat it as if I,
I'm always,
I'm aware of people's attention spans and anything interesting that I find I
give to Twitter and immediately I'll give it right back over your different
animal than say myself or Brian who,
if we should promote that,
people will just delete us and be like enough of that shit.
Shit.
They don't want to see our shit and
the guy,
where's the guy at that orgy fingering asshole?
You know,
I went to,
everyone came to fuck where the guys just pay pal,
even grosser.
I went to this one guy's Twitter.
I don't want to mention his name because I don't particularly like him,
but it's,
um,
it was all promoting some,
a special that's coming out and it was all like him tweeting celebrities using
the exact same worrying,
just having a different celebrities name,
hey blank.
Hey,
you know whoever Kim Kardashian,
Halacha boy and my specials coming out,
blah,
blah.
And it was his whole Twitter.
Was that,
is he an official Twitter?
Like a verified account.
Wow.
That's somebody that's somebody I wonder if that's even almost like an assistant
that's like,
no,
you're supposed to be,
could be.
It could be that or it could be just someone who's a,
doesn't know how to use social media and is an annoying cunt.
What's his name?
Ryan Wilson on,
we'll talk later.
Huh?
I tweeted the game on Sunday hour before my show started the game,
the rapper.
I was like,
Yo,
the game you in La.
I'm having a barbecue at my house.
Bring over some potato salad.
But I was just like,
if he does reply,
you've got a problem.
It's all my shit son.
Here's what I used to do.
Okay.
Ready?
This was the,
my favorite thing to do.
I used to go on to black centric 10 trend topics.
Okay.
Black Century trending topic is,
it's going to something,
there's going to be one that reads black,
like,
uh,
um,
like
mine was day gifts for the hood,
Valentine's Day,
gifts for the hood.
And so I thought it would be funny if in the end,
you know,
it's all like very,
it's black people being racist about black people.
It's just them writing like,
um,
get her a click clack,
you know,
she needs a gun in the hood,
get her another babies,
you know,
she's already got 10 yards.
How about child support son?
And so then I,
I wrote back,
how about anything dungeons and dragons son and no one got it right?
No one,
no one laughed at all.
And they started getting mad.
Like,
what are you doing in here man?
Get out white boy.
And then I was like,
give me nothing.
They said,
get out without white boy.
This is for the hood.
Don't you read the trend topic?
And I'm all right,
how about a classy pen?
And they're like,
oh no,
I see pen,
like what the fuck?
And then I was like,
all right,
all right.
All right,
one more chance.
How about a bottle of champagne?
But you spraying all over like a Ho and they're like,
that's more like it does dancer,
Girl.
I got tons to grow on them.
And so girls started I and I started doing them and it was like,
I forget the woman we,
I know it saved in my phone,
but like I said,
girl on them and I was just,
I was like,
don't write anything racist.
Just right.
Very good suggestions that you would think like one was things black people
scared of.
And then,
and this is a,
this,
so this is a trending topic.
How do you start a trending topic?
If you want any topic is pound sign.
And then one word,
I'll tell you what he's been like,
whatever it is.
One word all in one word,
right?
Like what are black people scared of would be no spaces.
All one Charlie sheen has been winning,
winning,
winning tiger blood.
And then the trend topics right now is what's dead in 2011 why?
Why can't you just so I'm sure.
It's like,
why can't you just pick up your baby girl?
When you say to pick up your pens,
this one's asked a little twist.
Okay.
See knows is perfect for your fans.
I'm sure I'm not,
I don't think he's a scientist.
I'm going to say he doesn't teach much.
Google little twist.
I'm
guessing a child wrapper.
Whenever something like this happens,
I get,
I really feel so out of it.
Man.
When I hear about this child born in 93 Jesus Christ,
he was born when I was auditioning for news radio at graduate.
That's when he shot out of his mom's box 93 wow.
I was still in college.
His name is Christopher Elmore.
Born January 11th,
1993 better known as his stage name,
Lil twist hall.
He's a rapper,
an American rapper from Dallas.
He signed onto Lil Wayne's label.
Oh,
that's why he's lil little twists Lil Wayne.
I don't rapper.
I don't understand a little ones under six feet is what they would probably say
a little.
Wayne is a fascinating cultural icon to me.
I watch his music and I am completely perplexed.
It's like a language.
I just do not speak.
It doesn't,
whatever it is,
it just doesn't get me.
I don't,
I don't understand it.
They are fucking,
he is huge man.
He is gigantic.
Massive.
He's,
he couldn't be bigger.
He's one easy.
The biggest rapper ever or one of them?
Yes.
You see
as the biggest rapper,
his,
the most commercially successful rapper right now.
I think probably ever.
I feel like I should give them another chance.
I feel like some reason why I'm here,
here comes the black end me out earlier stuff is much better than his later
stuff.
When he was at the hot boys,
he was amazing.
I ran into him in juvenile it,
him juvenile and like they had a man who was four of them at,
at,
at New Orleans and his earlier stuff.
He was good man.
He had rhymes that will blow you away.
Wow.
So now everyone just go on the little twist ankle twist trend topic and ask very
insightful questions that you know,
little twist doesn't have the answer for just non gold.
Try to be racist.
The whole goal is not to be racist.
It's just to be like,
seriously?
Do you think there's,
you know,
light forms out in the universal twist and like just see what little twists.
His answer's really is an answer for that and listen,
a little twist,
we're up to the Internet.
He might be smart as fuck.
Yeah.
The thing about kids today man,
you can never underestimate them.
It's not like they don't have the same access to information that we do.
When we were kids we were retarded because no one told the shit.
We are figuring things out like little monkeys just wandering around our
neighborhoods,
but now there's no more neighborhoods.
Man.
This is the whole world man.
Those stupid rumors that you heard about dude,
I heard that Rod Stewart Hud to get his stomach pumped and there was a gallon of
speaks Berman's od,
you know like those,
those stupid fucking stories.
Only w w w like lingered and worked because we didn't have anything else.
You know,
that shit would never fly today.
Like do Richard Gere,
which by the way I heard was my herd.
This is my room.
Um,
I heard that that was Scientology spreading that rumor to fuck with him because
he left Scientology.
Yeah,
that's what I'd heard.
I just,
I might have just made that shit up.
What's,
what's good school?
Good out here.
I'll tell you the,
so this is the trend topic I started was,
and this is what this brings it back to our conversation yesterday I started
doing a trend topic.
What will the main think when she sees this?
That was the trend topic.
Okay.
So then I started leaving the hotel room in a manner so that the maid walked in.
She would go,
what the fuck happened in here at now you're on your Twitter right now.
I'm just going to tweet these Joe.
And I'm telling you when I say this,
this might be my opus.
This might be the funniest than anything of our dominant stage.
I definitely think that I'm on the home page and I'm tweeting tweet.
I'm tweeting the first and there I am assigned to you.
So this is the,
and it's going chronologically.
I've gotten much better as you'll see my later work look much like little wanes.
So your early inspired shit was really good.
I just started getting to the next level.
Like Adam Richman's started doing them too and then he started challenging me on
Twitter and then people were like,
dude,
you guys are fucking,
and then I started like really thinking out of the box and I got into this
Jackson Pollock hyper like tweet the shits on.
I'm trying to,
we know all the written it.
Where the fuck is it?
It's coming up right now.
And so I got into this like manic state when I was in New York to impress and I
was trying to come out with them to promote the show and I was getting some good
ones man.
Like really fucking impressive.
I mean like some good shit.
I guarantee you there's artists on Twitter that go,
you've got great conceptual boundaries or whatever.
I'm telling you Joe,
user artists on Twitter,
they can teach you how to tweet up a fucking twit.
Here we go.
It's coming up right now,
sending tweet.
There we go.
Who's your cell phone service?
Cricket one.
There's a second one and a third one should be coming up to,
oh my goodness.
Here we go.
What will the main think when she sees this?
Okay.
Blind clicking.
Completely blind.
Okay,
I click this.
Oh,
he's got the bed made up.
Look like a nun.
Now mind you.
This is my early work.
Wait,
wait til you go through it and see how good has got.
I'll read.
Tweet it.
I'll retweet it so you can get a bed.
Fucking beautiful.
There's a bunch of them when you were,
I've got more than I could post right now.
I just went to this new stuff on the road.
Look at number two with that one though.
This frigerator will looks like Amanda Body Torso with clothes.
That's hilarious.
This is my,
I'm telling you,
I'm in.
Meanwhile,
the real sad part is and means probably not going to see it.
It's gonna be the next guest.
Fucking amazing cleaning that Lazy Bitch.
She's tired.
I talk about this all the time,
but I always,
the third one doesn't work,
Bro.
The third link doesn't work.
I would go now go to the,
go to the latest recent
paper.
Anything.
I'm fucking,
he made a fuck a dog.
This is hilarious.
It was talking about three hours,
three hours.
Fucking hotel room.
Just whacked out with a bottle of wine areas.
Just I retweeted the first and let me retreat the second one.
This hotel in Portland,
we are just in.
I easily do the whole come thing and I don't know.
I don't really do that.
I don't really normally do it as much as I say.
I am not saying I haven't done that,
but this time I decided to do it because I was in bed and I was like,
look,
I didn't want to wipe it on the bed and want to get out,
so I threw it like kind of up behind me and it went straight down on my iPhone.
Good.
I hope it gave your iPhone eight and Karma.
I hope your iPhone dies.
Do you think [inaudible] starts getting a cough?
We're,
we're talking about bird crushes.
Hilarious pictures.
You got to talk about shooting your own lower hotels.
No,
we're talking about some,
my very specific thing that this guy's doing.
It's very hilarious.
I love the birth conquer one Sunday at eight genius.
That's genius.
Tweeted all these folks.
And if you're listening to this on the podcast,
go back to the day that we recorded this,
which is April 5th on Tuesday 3:30 PM Pacific Time.
So if you want to find those tweets because they'll get lost in the mix.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
they're very funny.
And then I was talking to have fraud on the other day on doing radio and he was
in Pittsburgh and headphones.
Like I love those pictures.
I was like,
why don't you do them?
And he was like,
he was like,
I,
you know,
I thought of it but I didn't want to steal it.
Like I don't want to do it and feel like a stolen,
like go have fun.
And this is to any comic listening.
I don't give a shit do it.
But you got to tweet it to me cause I want to see it.
Right.
I don't want to copy your shit one day.
So this is the tweet.
It's,
what would the main,
what is the,
uh,
the Hashtag,
I didn't put the Hashtag in there,
but what would the main think when she sees this?
And that's why all one word,
all one word.
What would the maid think when she sees this?
And just tweet it to Burt and let's,
let's fucking get his one is great.
The,
I have the guy who's jumping out the window.
Yeah,
I did that one in Canada last minute and they all happen at the last minute.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So this one,
fags,
look at this,
this,
that's the one had in Richmond.
He was like,
he was like,
you cheated.
I go,
what do you mean I cheated?
He goes,
you fucking,
you gotta use the Shit in the room.
And I go,
no,
I use the shit in the room.
That's towels,
Napkins and catch up.
And he was like,
what the fuck did,
he just owned him?
That's why he's upset.
He,
you can't compete with this.
I would quit the game if you were playing this game.
I'd be like,
this guy's Ted playing this game way serious or than I am barely.
We need to have,
you need to have a part on your website that has a collection of these cause
that if that becomes big,
which I,
it seems like it would be,
you need to be the center homebase of essay should go home and immediately did
it.
Travel Channel got Ahold of it and they're like,
they're like with all that,
we want to use it to promote the show.
We're going to do a caption contest.
We're going to do,
we want to send them out and they're not,
and then they called one day I was in Mexico and they're like,
and I wasn't sleeping.
And they're like,
I need,
we need seven more.
Why have seven?
What the fuck do you think I'm a meth?
How am I going to come up with seven?
And they're like,
just do it.
Just do it.
And I was like,
I couldn't.
And I was sitting in Mexico fucking no TV listening to the Joe Rogan podcast on
experience on my iPad in bed with me in a pillow next to me cause I couldn't,
I was,
I was having anxiety and I was fucking flipping out and it's like,
it's the best.
I would put it on low.
So I feel like friends or talking in the next room puts me to sleep.
I just sit there and I just,
and then you wake up and you hear dog,
dog,
dog Joey.
He wakes me up every time.
Anytime he talks to you,
more people complain about Joey and his volume control is Joey.
Joey will lean back like this list.
Here's what the problem is,
Joanne,
we got a fucking problem there.
Brian just fucking cock sucker.
And then I'll get right up in there and you're like,
oh Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
he's someone I feel like I really missed.
I don't even think I want to meet him.
Like I just,
cause I want to just have him be the personality he is.
You know,
he is Joey,
you don't got to worry about meeting them.
Yeah.
It's even better than me.
Yeah,
you meet them and your love him.
He's,
he's the most unique human being I've ever met.
Well,
he tells a story about his mom.
I don't like his,
his stories.
He tells a story and it's,
he's the best,
one of the best storytellers because he leaves out the parts that make you stop
and wonder.
And then right when you're wondering,
he hits you with a fucking joke,
but he tells you the story about like the playing cards with his mom.
Gay.
I don't think so.
I guess he was,
I thought there were lesbians in the story,
but there and she'd go shake your hand Joey.
Shake your hand.
Shake his name and his underwear.
This sounds like a fucking TV show.
Like I don't know how this guy has not gotten a TV show.
One of the most interesting guys I've ever fucking list.
It's so crazy.
That's why.
Remember when he got pissed off for nothing?
We were on the way to the Gig.
Right?
And they were in the lobby and the show starts in like,
Yo,
I'm 20 minutes or 15 minutes,
wherever the fuck it is.
And so,
um,
I had a downstairs dog.
I've been waiting for you down here for half an hour dog.
When we be hanging there like this,
I go,
don't worry about it.
When the show starts,
when we get there,
come on dog.
You know me dog.
I get you can't leave
me hanging here like this dog and he wouldn't drop and he got crazy.
It got to like the like that times five more levels like dogs.
You don't have to give me respect.
Nikki,
lead Donny and waiting for your dog.
What are you talking about Joey?
It will take it.
Meanwhile,
I'm trying to discuss whether or not I should tell him that I had to take a
meaty shit.
Took a little longer than I thought it was going to take a look.
It's not like I don't want to be on time for my own fucking show.
All right,
we're here.
No one's dying.
Carrie will be there in five minutes forever.
I've known him for like 1112 years now,
maybe even 13 I might've met him and yeah,
it might be 13 years.
Fuck,
that's crazy.
He was drawing a picture in the green room while Joe was talking to some friends
and he goes,
pride record this.
And I'm like,
what?
okay.
So I started recording him,
just drawing something and then he pulls up the Sinus,
says Brian Loves Taylor Vixen,
who's my ex.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
And then he pulls out his balls and puts his balls behind it and I'm just like,
Jesus Christ man.
It's like Joey Diaz.
His balls in a room that's small is deadly.
I bet his balls are massive.
It's massive.
When two queers should go get a room.
Yeah.
But what Joey did is he made a funny video to Brian's x cause Brian and made a
couple of other funny videos.
He just,
he's torturing her,
torturing her.
Joey D is,
it's torturing me.
Then you sending him.
Oh,
I'm sending them together.
Funny.
I think it's funny night.
Like torture.
It's not touch her.
I'm not saying torture like you're hurting her.
Torture also means fun.
You know,
like,
oh,
he's fucking torture.
It doesn't necessarily mean you're trying to hurt her.
I see she has an RSS feed.
I don't even know what that right.
Shut the fuck up please.
Oh,
is this the whole fucking bill burr argument?
by the way,
which continued on to build burrs,
podcasts,
and now apparently under Greg Fitzsimmons is podcasts shut up,
which is even more ridiculous.
I was did,
it's so disappointing.
And Bill,
when I heard him talking on his own podcast about it,
I'm like,
wow,
you're re,
and then here's the worst part about,
he goes,
and I just want it to say I won.
I tried to talk to my lawyer.
My lawyer said that I could sue.
Okay,
I won.
And I was like,
Jesus Christ.
So many go find bill and give him a fucking hug.
That guy,
it's so ironic that bill was talking shit about people who smoke weed.
If anybody needs wait,
it's built by.
Oh,
he could definitely use a bulleted.
Super intense.
That's what everyone in Boston is like.
Yeah,
very similar.
it's a hard place.
And that's why comedy there,
it's such a good place to grow up and start doing comedy because you learn very
early on to appreciate people's attention spans because they will fucking blew
you off the stage with the quickness.
We did.
I did a show.
What was the comedy connection coming to connections and new hall Jamieson tour.
It was me,
Billy Gardell,
uh,
Steve Bernan,
Danny Bevins I think.
Yeah.
And we had to do the show to get renewed to do the show to get the tour renewed.
So the tour was a dick
load of money for us.
Right.
It was like a pho four grand a weekend and you only had to do is 20 minutes.
Wow.
And Billy Gardell is like Billy,
I mean this is,
I probably shouldn't talk about at a school about Billy,
but Billy had just quit drinking and he's sober now,
but had just quit drinking like that Thursday and was like,
I'm never touching it again.
And we've got to go and he's fucking freaking out.
And he's like,
you got to close the show.
And I got to follow like three guys and they're all fucking bang,
Bang Bang in Boston.
And I'm nervous about doing well in Boston because I kind of do race.
I used to do a lot of race stuff then and I was like fuck.
And I just came out the gates and I was like,
and just,
I just gave it everything I had just Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
And then like 15 minutes in,
I'm like,
if I can kind of keep this energy going,
then we fucking,
and I had a good set and we got the tour renewed.
But uh,
of course just fucking dumped on some black guy in the front row of the whole
time.
He loved that he was with a white check.
She had red hair.
Is that some weird when the girl was like,
Huh?
But that was,
yeah,
if I was my only experience in Boston.
Yeah.
Boston's a fun place.
Fun Town.
Too Bad.
It gets too cold.
Never lived there again.
Sorry.
Love you guys.
I couldn't live there.
Great place for comedy though.
When you live in a place where it's done fucking harsh,
you know,
that kind of an environment.
And now,
I mean it's,
well you think,
you know,
a lot of good comics come out of la too.
So that argument kind of sucks.
But we'll start in la.
Yeah.
Some of them do.
Who?
I've met some comics.
It started out here.
Holtzman star right here,
didn't he?
He did.
Right.
I know.
I know guys who've started out here that are really good.
It's um,
I mean you could start anywhere,
man.
I started in New York.
I did it once in Tallahassee and a,
and then move right to New York.
Did it in New York and got my lunch buddy taken really fucking quick.
But just,
I though my first time ever on stage,
this Guy Louis Shaffer was like I said I wanted to be a comic.
So I,
and it was,
it's a long story.
My Dad gave me one of those phone calls you don't ever want to have from a
parrot where he called me one morning on my birthday,
I'm expecting a birthday phone call and he calls me.
He's like,
you're pathetic.
You make me sick to my stomach.
Well,
I'm embarrassed of you.
You said you were going to be a comic.
You got rolling stone,
wrote an article about you and you said you're going to move and be a comic and
you've been there eight months and you haven't done shit.
And I lie,
I lie about you.
Like judges say,
how's your son doing?
And I lie.
Do you know what that makes me feel like?
And I'm just,
it's my first day.
Oh,
sitting,
hung over on my end,
my underwear on my couch that I grew up on in New York.
I had had it up there and my dad's just like,
and I was like,
he's like our failed you as a parent.
I failed you.
You have no humility.
I don't know what to do.
Just keep doing what you do.
I guess.
Get a fucking job.
I was,
we have no humility.
I had,
I had no humility at the time.
I just didn't,
I didn't have the,
like I was like,
I want to be a comic,
but I didn't know how to go about getting it because I felt like I was too good
to work the door or to,
you know.
Does that make any sense when I say that I felt like I was too,
I was,
I was too good to just get in at the ground level.
I wanted to be discovered.
I want it to be
brought down on.
I don't know.
I mean that's just,
I think a lot of people are like,
yeah,
I think a lot of people that,
how old were you?
26 and also,
yeah.
And I was too young to,
the open mic scene was all alternative comedy and like Demitri Martin and I
started around the same time and Dimitri just got welcomed by them and I hung
out and no one ever talked to me and I was like,
ah,
fucking great.
So then I just hung out the comedy clubs and drank in the back of company.
You know what I've always found ironic about alternative comedy is it,
a lot of alternative comics were like outcasts and they,
you know,
they felt like,
they were kind of nerds or whatever you will.
And meanwhile they're like the least welcoming the most,
I mean end the weirdest like backstabbing dish caddy ish.
It's very strange that you would think that the people that were picked on would
be like really open and warm and friendly.
Yeah,
they were,
they were brutal.
I would go to,
uh,
I forget the name of the fucking surf reality and a collective unconscious and I
would hang out,
try to do sets and no one would speak to me.
No one would speak to me and I would just be sitting there and Dimitri would
talk to me and then he literally would come and talk to me and then walk away
and talk to all of them and then come back and talk to me.
And I was just fucking and,
but I never felt like it all turns that you though.
Or is it though?
I would try to talk to people and whenever I said they'd make fun of me,
like I remember he would make fun of you first.
Anything out of my mouth,
they just go,
ah,
okay.
Okay.
And this is the comics.
This is the comics.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because they wanted you to feel uncomfortable.
We wanted me to feel horrible.
Isn't that weird?
Oh,
it's the worst.
And then I'm,
and then I'd go to,
I go to common though.
Oh,
go,
go.
I'm,
I'm the,
I'm generalizing and I don't want to do that,
but go hang out at fucking,
I'm trying to think of UCB,
UCB and see how,
like I know Tom said he went and did the,
they have a comic book.
I did a set there once and I had a great time.
I only did it once and I remember somebody pointed me to thread somewhere where
the people said they actually enjoy the show,
but they were like,
what the fuck is Joe Rogan
hear it?
That's so stupid.
But
it is,
but it isn't.
You know what I mean?
They're,
they're expecting a certain particular type of comedy that maybe makes them feel
good,
but your comedy is the same.
That's what really upsets not upsets me.
I don't give you shit personally.
I'm not looking to get spots at a,
at a comic bookstore,
but I did a comic book store,
Jet Tubs,
gorgeous,
did one,
and he said he was great.
I did it for a Dunkin.
It was awesome.
Dunkin,
but Duncan Duncan is kind of welcomed.
It was welcomed everywhere.
Don't get genius.
He can float between worlds,
but what were you saying?
So I had no humility.
That's what they get,
what it gets to,
and it was just,
I would sit in the back of comedy clubs.
I think
this,
how does this translate?
This is where I'm confused.
You say you say you have no humility.
At the time you thought you were too good,
but yet here you are in these alternative rooms and everyone's treating me like
shit.
Do you think they're connected?
I'm sure there were.
I'm sure that my perception of what the status quo of comedy clubs was perceived
from way I'd been treated,
but I'd go to,
I'd go to like the Boston comedy club with the seller and I'd say hide it to
tell and Norton,
they were all cool,
but they,
you know,
they were also working comics and I was,
that's what I wanted to be.
And I think my dad,
well my dad's note was,
was my dad's kind of guy that if he wanted something he would get it and he'd go
and he'd say,
this is what I want.
Can you please help me get this?
And I would not that guy just hanging out in the back of the club and go in
their defense,
in any buns defense when it comes to hanging out when new people,
man,
I try to be as friendly and as open with everybody that I can.
New Comics,
I love talking to new comics,
but man,
there's a certain point in time,
sometimes in the middle of a conversation when you realize,
Oh,
I'm stuck talking to this dummy.
You know that that's annoying man.
When you have a good group and a good vibe,
you know,
so maybe you came off like too loud or too,
he didn't say a word really.
I was mad.
I will be your stage.
Your Act.
I went from this toy they judging you from.
He never got on stage.
So what were they judging you from?
Uh,
I was nice.
I everyone liked me but that I,
the alternative people didn't.
What would the,
you must have said a word because you said that they were mocking you for saying
anything.
Oh,
the alternative comics.
Yeah,
I'd go up and I would didn't know how to do stand up.
Oh,
so you did go up on stage in front of them.
Reality and collective unconscious,
but you paid three bucks and go up at the end of the night.
That was how that those rooms work.
Right?
Well then you can understand why they didn't want to talk to you.
Right.
I can understand that.
They want to talk to me,
brought me back to the fuck.
I mean we're just,
I have to break down everything.
That's where they weren't funny either.
It's not like anyone was of course.
Right.
They would laugh at whatever they said because they had said it and it also was
a certain sensibility to write.
My Shit was like,
I was trying to be funny in any comedy club anyway.
We're trying to be funny in any comic con was just trying to be funny.
I didn't know what I didn't know there's a difference in alternative.
There isn't.
I didn't know we were talking about that before.
You know about this.
This guy that they were saying is the founder of alternative comedy and we both
agreed like he's not even an alternative comics.
Just a comic,
you know what does that even mean?
You know who I think was the the founder of alternative comedy as far as I know,
if it all came out of Boston supposedly it all came out and catch a rising star.
It was David Cross Cause David Cross was doing like really weird shit.
He was named Martin.
Oh well Steve Martin is a an icon.
I mean Steve Martin is a different thing.
He's not what David Cross did.
Here's one of the things he did.
Let me give you an example.
He put on a stretching tape for like a warmup exercise tape and then he starts
stretching and talking on stage about a stretching and it was,
I don't know why,
but it was silly.
It was,
there was something funny about it,
but it was completely ridiculous that he was just taking this chance to go
onstage.
But like a lot of people weren't laughing,
but everybody has a smile on their face.
Like,
what the fuck is he doing?
It was fun.
Steve Martin was a comic.
He's just silly.
I'll often did a lot of alternative stuff on stage,
you know,
alternative stuff.
Like what?
Like he would do banjo stuff.
He would do like banjos alternative.
That's not an alternative alternative.
The idea of alternative is like hipster.
It's like Nerdy,
super smart,
you know?
That's what alternative comedy supposed to be like.
Not Too loud,
not too physical.
Steve Martin is the antithesis of that.
He's the absolute opposite of what you would consider alternative comedy.
I can't put my finger on alternative comedy per se.
Uh,
whether it is or it isn't,
but I can put my finger on what alternative comics dislike.
Like I can go on the road and go shower this guy.
Would you see guys on the road where they're act as just like,
Ugh,
bearable.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
Well,
and I think what they think is that is the comedy that goes on,
not in UCB.
That is a comedy that's everywhere.
And that is like,
I don't think a lot of them go on the road and see what you do on the road or
see what the road's like.
Well,
eventually the road becomes the same everywhere.
I'm going to tell you that my crowds are there sometimes more enthusiastic in
different towns,
but they're all the same now.
It's everybody's there.
They're all,
they all know what I'm doing.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's not an issue anymore,
but when you're young and no one knows who you are and you go on stage,
if you're used to doing the UCB and getting those really polite laughs and
chuckles in the back of the room with some witty,
uh,
you know,
reference that you made,
to some fucking do novel.
You know what I'm saying?
Something about the spice and everyone in the UCB thinks it's so funny.
Do that shit.
And Tallahassee,
Florida,
they'll throw bottles at you,
motherfucker.
You know there's a problem with,
you know,
when no one knows who you are,
man.
That's when it's really tough.
When you're not bringing in your own crowd.
You could get really soft easily if you're a name and you know,
you have a bunch of people that come to see you all the time and you know,
they give you so much love and they want you to succeed.
They want to laugh.
They're not like,
they don't have any arms crossed staring at you sideways.
Yeah.
Good comedies,
good comedy.
I mean it like Patton.
Oswald makes me laugh.
I don't give a fuck what anyone says.
He makes me giggle.
You know,
like our first,
one of my favorites,
first time I ever saw him on stage,
he was like,
dude,
like he's really big in the alternative comedy scene.
And I was like,
Oh really?
And then he just murdered and it wasn't alternative.
It was just funny.
Yeah.
Well that's big in the alternative comedy scene because he's a comic book nerd
and he loves science fiction and you know,
he fits in physically,
you know,
so the the except him.
But he's a great writer.
That's what he is.
He's,
he's his modem to be bass.
I got it.
Yeah.
I haven't read it yet,
but I picked it up,
put in perspective now to get to what,
to bring it full circle if this is possibly it at all possible.
So that is who I was in New York in 1997 trying to fit in,
trying to break my way into comedy through having beers with comics and not
fitting in an alternative and not being,
having the gumption or the gregariousness to break in in the,
are you doing sets or was it I was,
I don't even know what the fuck I was doing.
I was working out at Barnes and noble.
So you are working at Barnes and noble,
you no working out,
working out,
uh,
this is bad.
You do sets of bonds?
No,
most working at Barnes and noble and then working out during the day and the
basement,
like I was fucking,
I got fired from Barnes and noble.
This is the worst I was working at Barnes and noble and astro place.
No fucking AC.
And so everyday I would you ever have a job where you lift boxes and as you do
you're like that's not a bad,
that's a good buy workout.
And you're like,
oh,
all right,
I'll do a little bit of this.
And if I do this all day long,
I'm fucking jacked buys by the end of the summer.
So I'd go down to the basement and you can take the freight elevator.
I'm going to sound like a psycho into five minutes.
You could take the freight elevator to the basement and no one could get down
there cause you had the elevator.
And so once I got to the basement,
I take off my clothes and start working out and just like do pushups,
sit ups,
fucking curls with boxes,
whole books out,
two fucking these fucking jobs,
front rows.
And I'd work out.
And then it was,
there was no AC.
So then I'd wait till I cooled down,
put all my clothes back on,
get the freight elevator walk up and I just killed like 30 minutes.
When you have a job like that to kill 30 minutes is a,
it's like fucking calm that much closer to being over done.
So I'm like,
this is an eating ripped fuel to remember ritual and pop and fucking three
refuels every three hours.
Right?
Oh my God,
like a tweaker running around Shelvin travel books,
go down to the basement,
pounding like I'm in fucking Oz just and then come up sweating like a
motherfucker with a name tag on just,
and so like two weeks into it,
my boss Duane pulls me aside and he was like,
he was like,
Hey man,
you've been spending a lot of time in the basement.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
cause I gotta get travel books and that's where we keep them all down there.
And he's like,
yeah,
do you know we have video cameras?
And also like I didn't know that and he's like,
you're fucking fired.
And I was like,
wow,
I did Dwayne.
I can explain it.
He goes,
no,
I can't,
I can't have someone getting into their underwear basement working out,
doing they should be working.
And then coming back up and then interacting with people.
And I was trying to be a comic,
so I was trying to think alternatively.
And I'm on speed,
which is Kim.
So theoretically like I would do funny shit,
but it was crazy if you didn't know me exactly.
Some guy told you the day we were doing a promo shoot phrase directv and I did a
joke at the end of the day,
like it was that funny.
He goes,
Bert,
everything you do is only funny if you've spent fucking 24 hours with you.
And so yeah.
So I got fired and then came home.
I'll be great to have that tape if anyone at Barnes and noble.
And so his name is Dwayne.
I remember he asked me if I wanted to be a manager like a week before that.
And I was like,
no.
And it was like,
what?
And I was like,
he was like,
you don't wanna be a manager?
And I was like,
no.
He's like,
why?
Why do you w w what do you want to do?
Then I was like,
I want to be a comedian.
And I was like,
oh,
this isn't what I do.
And he looked at me dead in the face.
He goes,
this is what you do.
This is who you are.
You worked at Barnes and noble.
Don't think you're better than us.
You're not,
fuck,
I'm out of here soon.
I didn't know I was going to get fired,
but
don't think you're better than us.
Yeah,
that was a,
there was a guy that I went,
I was driving limousines and had that same attitude.
He would get pissed at me if I wanted to go home after work in eight hours.
Cause I was like,
I'm gone man.
I gotta I gotta go,
I've got a Gig to do.
And he was like,
Hey,
yeah,
eight hours is nothing around here,
you know,
it's a lot.
A lot of the guys doing 12,
15 hour shifts.
I go,
okay,
good,
good for them by,
and they leave
and uh,
you know,
and he's like,
what makes you think that job's going to be in him?
And I go,
dude,
I worked eight hours,
I got to go.
I've got a Gig.
Goes,
where's your Gig?
So I told them when the Gig was,
well,
the GIG got switched.
It was one of those things where,
you know,
like a,
it was a,
you know,
a little hundred dollars gig or something like that.
And one of the booking agents,
uh,
you know,
I'd called him up and he said,
hey,
would you rather do this one in Connecticut?
It's a pays one 50.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes.
One.
So he switched me,
you know,
and move me to this other place.
So asshole calls the first place and I'm not there.
He goes,
yeah,
I called that fucking job.
You went there,
you know,
you're a liar.
I'm like,
Ooh,
it gets switched.
You fucking creepy stalker.
Like I work eight hours.
But his whole attitude was that he wanted to keep me a driver.
Like he,
they held me escaping.
I can feel it.
Yeah.
A lot of times.
Uh,
I mean,
I think that,
I think that goes with everything.
I even comedy.
Yeah,
sure.
People are haters,
man.
A lot of people it's way,
it's way easier for them if you're a failure,
the way easier for them.
If you're not ambitious,
if you're not there,
like when you're a guy and this poor fuck was like,
you know,
he's in his like late thirties,
and he smoked cigarettes and he just looked like a broken dream.
He had nothing going on,
you know,
and here he is a a dispatch guy for a limousine thing in Boston where you're
dealing with a bunch of fucking savages every day and you know,
he,
you see someone who's 21 and it just has all these crazy ideas in their head and
I'm going to do this,
I'm going to be a comedian.
And he's like,
see all this energy behind this person all these years.
You just want to squash that.
You want to throw water on that fire.
You know,
there's a lot of people,
man,
the last thing they want to see is someone with,
with,
with some sort of a spark inside of them.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a lot of people,
man,
that's terrifying to them.
They just don't want,
they don't want to see that man.
They don't want to see that.
They didn't want you to fuck up.
They want you to fail so they don't have to compare,
compare themselves to you unfavorably and then start thinking about what a
fucking disaster their life has been.
No,
that was everyone that worked at Barnes and noble
was broken.
There was one gay guy who had come from Iowa and just come out of the closet
like move to New York and then I think he knew he was gay the whole time they
got to New York and was like,
I'm fucking gay.
I remember him coming into work one day,
he's like,
I'm gay.
And I was like,
awesome.
And he's like,
no,
I can say it now.
I'm gay.
I and I'm so happy.
And I was like,
wow,
you man,
hold onto it.
For the longest time fought so much that first month,
that guy,
he got fucked out of his loft.
One night I came back with a black eye because he fell out a little office.
The guy was fucking him a them amount of the law,
this guy fuck nonstop that first.
That's,
that's so great.
Yeah.
So he was,
he was in the closet and your sexuality like,
like to realize you're straight and then everyone in the straight community is
like,
let's just fuck the shit out of this guy.
When it happens in the gay community,
straight community,
it doesn't work that way.
They're not really into switching teams.
It's like you're used to play for the red sox and now you want to play with the
Yankees.
What's all that?
What about that red sox sucks tattoo you got.
Oh,
but yeah,
so then,
okay,
now full circle.
So then I worked at Barnes and noble.
That's who I was.
I worked at Barnes Noble and then go to comedy clubs,
and so my dad,
after that,
at the end of that conversation I was like,
Dad,
I don't want to embarrass you and I want to tell me what to do.
It was my 26th birthday while he said,
you go to the club and you tell them you want to be a comic and you do anything
it takes to be a comic.
Can I go down to this?
Not how it works?
And he goes,
that's humility.
That's humility.
You walk into that front door,
you talked to the guy who runs a club and say,
you will do anything.
Your mop up your stack chairs,
you'll flip burgers,
you'll clean dishes,
and would have the kind of guy that cleans.
This is your task.
What I'm fucking talking about.
Have some humility and go in and do that.
So I went in to this guy,
Louis Shaffer.
Do you remember him?
Yeah,
the comic strip.
The solution solution called Louis Shaffer was a gay guy that worked down in the
village who always wear a blazer and a white shirt was safer.
What club?
Gay.
Not Gay.
What Club of Boston?
Boston comedy club.
Right.
Okay.
So I want it to Louis and I was like,
I want to be a comic.
And Louis was like,
this is the night of my birthday.
And he goes,
can I give you some advice?
I said,
yeah.
He goes,
go back to the Tampa and learn it there and then come back to New York.
You're in the big leagues right now.
And I was like,
that's,
I've already got an apartment that's not going to work.
And he's like,
well,
that's my advice.
And so I call my dad and I was like,
I want to,
he said to move back to Tampa and my dad goes,
perfect,
go in tonight and give them the same speech you gave him last night and say
you're going to do this until he fucking folds and gives you a job.
And so I was like,
all right.
So I went in that night,
like seven said the same thing to Lewis and Lewis said,
God,
I didn't,
I tell you to move back to Tampa.
And I was like,
I go,
well I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to keep hounding you.
And he said,
okay,
if you can stand out front and bring in 20 people throughout the night,
and then if there's still people in the room after Godfrey goes on,
I'll let you go up on stage.
And so I was like,
okay.
So that night to the fucking three people in four people in a girl named Karen
Berger Iin this onstage and for Puerto Rican guys who I brought in off the
street who are like,
one guy was going to prison the next day or said,
I just want anyone,
I brought a guy in with ice cream,
he had his groceries and I brought him in.
I brought everyone in the club,
they're sitting in the front row and they make Karen Berger and cry and Louis,
they go,
look,
Karen's crying.
And so Louis goes up,
you want to be a comic?
Now's your chance.
So he went up,
grab carrying Burger and he goes,
all right,
you guys ready for your next comic?
And brought me on stage.
And the only thing,
if anything that I could do was light up for Puerto Ricans and I got on stage
and I destroyed these guys one by one by one.
And when they'd talk I was be like,
listen,
when it says in my act,
the dumb Puerto Rican and rejects,
I'll point to you.
And He'd,
and he'd be like,
go out in the crowd.
Was going nuts and I was late people in the crowd besides that,
I was filling the fuck it was everyone that knew me,
I'd brought everyone in.
It was like fucking a hundred maybe a hundred people on a Thursday night and so
big it up and they leave the place goes nuts.
And he's my first time age in New York and I'm like,
oh,
I'm like,
or like on a real stage,
you know?
And I'm like,
yes,
I'm a fucking,
and then I was supposed to do a joke and I know many jokes and I was like,
fuck it bombed.
Got Off stage and loose is like,
you've got a job.
And I was like,
what?
And he goes,
come here every night at seven unlocked the place,
set the chairs up and bring in people all night long and I'll give you a spot.
Six months later,
literally,
and this brings it to bill burr.
Six months later I get a development deal with will Smith do work in the door
six months later like that.
And Bill Burke told me,
it was like,
it happens.
Don't feel guilty.
Everyone's going to dislike you.
But I was like,
Huh?
Did you get that?
Did you get a lot of resentment?
Yeah,
yeah,
a lot.
But I didn't care really.
Cause I was like,
oh fuck.
You sound like almost like,
I mean,
I love you man.
But you sound like almost like this hapless retard that stumbles upon success.
I am the luckiest guy in the luckiest guy in the world.
Literally the lead.
It's not just that.
It's your personality.
Is it very endearing and interesting and tough.
Great Story.
So it's not just that you're lucky it just to be you.
And this is the same thing when you were talking about Joey to be Joey.
It's,
it's,
you can't be Joey and market Joey.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like who Joey is,
Joey,
you know?
So it's almost like somebody else has to come along and find what's,
what's interesting about you.
Yeah.
You know,
but the fact that you like kept going after it,
you know,
and that you started out in New York in the village,
it's like one of the hardest places you could ever start doing.
Oh yeah.
I think if you can,
I always assimilate the two.
Like,
cause I,
then I moved to La,
so I got a TV show and then tried to do an la comedy in La and it was just
totally different.
And I remember Bobby Kelly came out and he was like,
I don't fucking,
I remember I was like,
I don't have this fucking witty shit.
I don't know what he shit,
I'm fucking real.
I'm a comic.
I'm a fucking New York comic.
I go up and I talk and he was like,
I don't fuck this witty shit.
I remember,
I don't remember.
He just kept saying,
fuck this witty shit.
I don't have witty shit.
I don't know.
Witty jokes.
Okay.
I don't know.
I remember,
all I remember is sitting in the back of the Improv with them.
Look man,
Joey Diaz has doesn't have a witty bone in his body.
But the funniest shit I've ever heard.
But Bobby,
yeah it doesn't have to be witty to me.
I consider the two difference.
I think both are like working out.
But New York is like working out in prison where you like it's just a fucking
steel bar with two cinder blocks and you just kind of trying to get size so you
don't get fucked in the ass in the shower.
And La is like doing like a typo or or like spin class.
So you that good.
You want to look good,
you want to look tight but you don't have to worry about getting fucked in the
shower cause it's not as bad.
Of course.
I've never done it at the store.
What la La Con,
New York comedy is like fucking in your face like the second you stand up.
It's not like an industry crowd.
It's fucking a bunch of fucking Persians that are in from and from Iraq.
And they were aware of her and then it's a fucking bunch of brothers and from
Harlem,
some kids from Spanish Harlem.
And they just like fucking lights you up,
but it's a little more aggressive.
La is a little more,
you get up and I remember the first time I realized I didn't have any like joke
jokes,
like I couldn't just start speaking like I needed to interact with someone
because that's what you'd always do in New York.
You just,
I mean it's,
it's your act is very organic because you talk to someone,
Hey,
where are you from?
Or Oh,
how'd you get here?
I don't know.
It just seemed like it.
I never did.
Even when I was in New York,
it seemed more of he never did that when I was in New York.
I just did my act.
Really?
Yeah.
No,
I never talked to crowd.
The only time I'd ever talked to the crowd as if there's a problem,
like you have to deal with something or if someone's just like really
outrageous.
I saw the guy,
what's the guys name he used to do?
Make me laugh.
Do you remember that?
The one on comedy central Mark Laugh have no idea.
Was all comedy central and you'd,
Jeff Ross was always on it.
I forget the guy's name.
He dated Terra Silver Minnis guy.
Okay.
Solve,
come to New York one day he was in La Comic and he got fucking stall like bad.
And I'd never seen someone bomb before like that where he couldn't come back.
It was just bits and uh,
and uh,
he would fucking eight
it hard to,
people are going to eat it,
they're gonna eat it everywhere.
But that was,
everyone in the club was like,
that's La comedy for you.
It's not even,
it's probably he was uncomfortable.
Yeah.
Probably uncomfortable and you know,
got on stage with a,
uh,
an attitude or felt
weird when he got out there.
That's half of it,
man.
Half of his being comfortable wherever the fuck you are,
which is the best thing about,
you know,
having fans that come to see you,
having people that,
that know what you do and they're coming to see,
you know,
I know Bert Kreischer,
he's hilarious.
I'm going to see Bert Kreischer,
you know,
as opposed to just coming to any club.
But that's,
that's how you develop your voice too by doing those,
those clubs.
But then you have to always think that if you're doing these clubs and no one
knows who you are and you're trying to get them to like you,
you know,
there's a,
there's a danger of maybe becoming something that you're not because you want
them to like you,
you know,
because you want to be more successful.
I get almost like it,
it hinders your ability to become yourself onstage.
And I'm talking about,
yeah,
I think so.
I mean,
how many guys have you seen that?
Like do a tell when they go onstage?
A lot.
Right.
And why are they doing it while they're doing it?
Because they know it works.
They know it works and it's successful and it,
it,
it gives them a charge when they're in the audience,
like they react to his cadence and then it becomes really catchy and then you
started to start doing it even almost subconsciously because you're just trying
to be effective.
You know,
you just trying to be effective up there.
Yeah.
I used to,
I used to steal from Mattel,
but I was young because I didn't know how to write a joke and you'd just be
like,
how the fuck would it tell?
Tell it.
Right.
I remember my first joke was a,
you know what cops hate when you touch their faces?
And I was just like,
that's an intel.
It's an Intel fucking set up punch.
It is.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Like he said that already.
No,
no,
no.
I just always thought that in my head.
Like,
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So it you,
you imitated him.
I would emulate what I,
when I'd write a joke,
I'd be like,
I got a funny premise because I was hammered on a flight to Scotland and a
stewardess was trying to cut me off and I knew she was cutting me off and I
didn't want her to say anything.
And so I just went and took my fingers lives to know it.
Like I didn't want her to cut me off.
And then I got really cut off.
This is well before nine 11 and so I told Patrice that happened in between.
It's like,
that's funny joke because the second you touch someone's face,
you take all their power away.
Like you touch someone's face.
It fucking just,
and he was like,
you got to fucking tell it.
So did you actually touch your face talking,
touch your face on it.
I was so drunk going to Scotland from La.
Wow.
And I just want it.
So what happened when you touched her face and she freaked out?
No,
she just was like,
all right,
you're done.
You're done.
And then,
and then serve me another beer at the end of the day.
Like what were,
we were getting a land.
She gave me another one.
Really?
I've been cut off planes a lot.
You never been cut off in a plane?
Never.
Where's the cutoff?
I'm out.
Like with like if you've got to be a sport.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm the least of noxious dot.
So it's not,
it's a number.
It's four.
Yeah,
it's four.
They won't serve you more than four drinks.
Is that first class as well?
No,
first class.
A totally different ball.
Yeah.
But if you put the finger,
you get control.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a pro at it now.
Number one,
if you're,
if you're a big drinker on plans,
this is how I do it.
Don't speak,
ever speak,
don't speak to anyone.
Just if you want to drink,
tap your cup.
Just Dude,
you're an alcoholic.
Okay.
Maybe I am not talking just so that you can get more alcohol.
The on plants.
I have a hard time flying.
I've fucking mathematics it flying.
You see you're telling us before the show that you have anxiety right now I
think I have horrible.
Yeah,
cause you seem a little like revved up today.
Like you're having a hard time like staying calm.
Yeah,
because I got to go skydiving on Saturday and so that's in the back of my head,
like the concept of,
so is that fucking with you while you're talking?
Do you hear it in the back of your hand?
You can Skype.
No,
I know if I got,
the bird is the only one right here.
That's not high.
So He's,
he's not on the same frequency as Brian and I,
I would totally.
Have you ever done skydiving?
No.
I'm not really into dying like that.
I'm sure it'd be fun as fuck.
But you know,
there's,
um,
I know two people that know people that have died and including Brian,
Brian's.
Brian's dad was supposed to go skydiving with this woman and she flattened out.
Boom,
hit the ground.
Another thing I heard too,
that I don't know if this is true or not.
I think we are talking about,
it's like how when you're skydiving,
it's really hard to breathe because it's so much air.
So the whole time you're just going like,
like,
you can't,
you're just trying to breathe.
You're focusing so much.
I'm starting to sweat now.
Now it's just really hard.
This guy sweating like a pig.
He's really sweating,
man.
I'm really sweating.
It's hot in here.
Yeah.
It's not that hot in here.
You guys are both fat.
What's going on right here?
If you were in,
you really knew somebody died.
Skydiving.
Yeah.
I knew someone else.
Um,
from a,
for some friends of mine in Houston,
there was a bunch of guys at skydived and you know,
I didn't know the guy.
He told me his friend died.
And then Brian's story,
that's to the two's enough.
Was he tandem?
I don't know.
I don't want to happen.
I think he was solo,
you know,
a thousand people.
They probably died in or knew people that died in car accidents though.
But you still drive a car.
I don't know,
a thousand people that have died in car accidents.
I thought Jesus Christ.
Nasscom I'm saying if you're going by like person that knows somebody that died,
you know,
like it.
Like you have friends that know somebody at Dion's skydiving.
Yeah,
definitely.
And what would be the difference,
Brian?
What are you talking about?
What would be the deputy chief,
these two guys to get to work and be,
you don't skydive.
Yeah.
Fucking day of your life.
I mean,
I'm not not skydiving because of people dying.
And that's the last thing,
really.
The first thing I'm thinking of.
What a fuck.
I would feel high if I'm pulling that thing and the parachutes not coming out
and I see that barn and I know I'm going to make a fucking Scooby doo hole
through it.
The shape of my body with my outstretched arms.
Boom.
I'm just going to hit the hay and I'll turn into a bag of Jello and broken
bones,
splat,
and basically just inside your helmet is jaw just broken?
That'd be fine,
but it's going to suck the the heights things.
Are you scared of heights?
Terrified of heights.
Yeah,
me too.
But you,
you,
you've been on roller coasters step.
You're going to be strapped into somebody else.
Also a professional.
Professionally,
I'm going to go tell you must be.
You have to,
you can't,
you can't just do it on your first time.
They don't want you to panic and just to shut off.
So I've been,
I've been sweating,
stressing about that like crazy.
That's freaking out.
Oh,
fucking like this show is a real mindfuck for you because you have to do a lot
of dangerous shit on this show.
We did.
We went,
we were doing a
concrete toboggan race where you get a 300 pound concrete Toboggan,
put five kids in it,
and then you race it down a mountain against another team who has a 500 or 300
pound car carvery Toboggan and you go 40 miles per hour,
no steering,
and you just fly it on a fucking mountain.
How do you stop it?
Uh,
they have breaks.
They have breaks,
but it depends on where your brakes are on the thing.
You may just fucking flip it.
Oh Geez.
It depends.
The two people before us,
the group before us,
Guy Goes,
uh,
they've ragdoll it.
They hit a berm.
Oh two breaks.
His girl breaks her arm in two places and all the bones in her hand and then
they go,
are you ready?
And I was like,
what?
My camera man is like,
dude,
a broken femur is a game changer.
It's a life changer.
Fuck yeah.
People lose,
lose their legs sometimes cause they,
when they try to reattach it,
but the femur back together can't do,
you can't get a blood supply going so it gets gangrene.
People lose their legs from Fema.
Yeah.
But yeah,
that was like one of the things,
I mean we went shovel racing and New Mexico.
Do you know what I mean?
What's that?
You just sit on a shovel and go down a mountain.
It's 70 miles an hour.
Jesus Christ.
Just sit on a shovel and then just hope you don't die and just sit back like
this.
I definitely didn't get 70 but guys are going 70 to 70 70 miles an hour on a
shovel.
A shovel,
no breaks.
Are you dealing with your fucking blue slope?
Like on a blue slip on skiing it goes blue diamonds.
It goes green,
blue and black and want a blue one that's like been loud shaved and like salted.
There's,
and you just are flying.
So that noise basically like the luge.
Oh it's,
it's exactly like a luge and but,
but with less like less control because you're on a shovel and,
and the,
the,
the Rogers stick in between your legs.
It's been,
I've learned a lot about myself with anxiety through this show.
Like I've learned a ton,
but I still,
I,
I'm still dictated by my anxiety.
Like there's certain foods I won't eat because I know it will fuck with me in
the middle of the night.
Oh,
it just wake up and have an anxiety attack.
There's certain foods trigger anxiety.
My stomach,
my stomach,
it dictates my anxiety.
It's heart palpitations.
Like some,
some foods like onions and stuff.
I know it makes my heart beat a little crazy here and there.
Make your heartbeat.
We buy food like the other night when my shit was all jacked up from being in
those.
How a peanut is a stuffed,
I can't fuck with Jalapeno.
Yeah,
it fucks.
If fucks my stomach up,
which then fucks my heart up,
which makes me like fucking like conscious of my heart and then I'm like
freaking out.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You don't get any anxiety about that stuff.
Do you,
have you ever had an anxiety attack?
No.
Never.
It's weird.
Really,
really weird.
Here's what Liam,
it sounds really weird to not have an anxiety attack.
No.
I mean like most people I thought always ha.
Never like,
okay,
this is one of the things I don't like about what you think that's true at all.
Like you were saying,
had some,
I'll let me clarify.
I've had some paranoid moments on weed for sure.
I've had some moments,
but I think those are very important.
I think those are the ones that make you reevaluate yourself that I don't like
reevaluate those going to like know what my son I like
being scared as fuck with.
That's exactly because you're,
oh no,
no,
no.
It's not anxiety because I'm not panicking.
I'm just terribly,
terribly,
terribly aware of everything and it's not,
it's not a panic attack.
It's just an acceptance of the whole picture.
It's never where I don't feel like I'm,
I'm,
I can handle it or I'm going to freak out and my heart's beating too fast.
It's never that.
It's just the humbling aware feeling and awareness of the big picture.
You know?
I like that.
I think it's very important.
People take drugs to get away from that feeling on me,
man.
I go into it,
I run into it.
That's what the tank is.
The tank accentuates.
Any feeling that you get if you ever been to high in like freaked out.
I go in the tank when I'm too high.
One of the,
the higher I get like that's the more I want to get in the tank because you face
it and you come out of it and you always learn something.
Always.
I always know more about myself.
I always know whether I'm on the right track as far as like,
you know what it,
is there anything else in my subconscious?
It's fucking with me.
Is there anything that has bothered me?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I go right in there man.
See,
I'll obsess about anything.
If you can,
if you can give me a,
if you can give me something,
I'll mull it over my head.
Like when I had to jump off the stratosphere,
I literally was up the night before throwing up in a bathtub.
Do you feel like you're making progress with all this crazy critic?
Yes,
I am.
I'm definitely making progress,
but uh,
like I'm definitely making progress.
Right.
But I,
but I still,
I think the stratosphere,
by the way,
it's going to be a lot scarier than skydiving.
Really?
Yeah.
Because you're going to be able to see like a kind of like a point of distance
or,
I mean like crazy.
Nobody's died in the stratosphere.
Skydiving is you,
you're so far removed from what the best I'm saying did it doesn't freak you
out.
Right?
No,
that makes total sense.
I mean,
if you're standing on top of a really tall building,
you can fucking see that you're really high up because you could see other
things at the same level or below or higher.
So it gives you more of a,
an idea that you're really high referenced.
Yeah.
When you're up it up,
you know,
plain,
sure it's high.
But it's also like,
almost like cartoony fake,
like,
yeah.
If you're retarded,
I dunno man.
To me it looks like a Goddamn plane flying 30,000 fucking feet above the earth.
He's just going 16 it's to take a long time to hit the ground.
16,000 feet hit the ground quite twice as quick.
Good.
And it's a one of those planes that just falls from the sky every now and then
those skydiver planes.
Wait,
what kind of a fucking plane can you open up a door in the middle of the flight?
That's a drug claim,
right?
I think you're going to be fine.
Drug planes,
man,
if that,
if that pilot has a mustache,
it might be screwed.
So drug planes crash all the time.
Did you ever see that one that crashed in Mexico for four tons of cocaine inside
of it?
They ran out of gas.
CIA plane.
Yeah.
It's fucking one of the greatest stories of all time.
CIA plane headed went to Guantanamo Bay on two separate occasions.
Clearly a CIA plant,
four tons of cocaine in it.
Crashes in Mexico's Mexicans won't let them refuel cause they know what the fuck
they're doing.
By the way,
Portland was fucking amazing.
Have you been to Portland and Sheila who was saying that?
I want to,
I want to.
I'm going this year.
I just don't know.
The
Portland didn't have a major comedy club for the longest time,
so
it was hard for comics that tore through Portland.
But then they just put this helium place and I had done Portland before.
I did a theater there and it was great.
But this was really fun because we got to do three nights,
you know,
five shows over three nights.
Everything sold out way in advance.
It was all podcast fans,
you know.
And that's the,
the thing that Brian and I had been talking about it a lot lately and I was
talking with you about it in the kitchen.
Everything has changed.
It's completely different.
You know,
the,
the people that are coming to shows are way more enthusiastic.
It's,
it's way different,
you know,
they know you better.
It's,
it's a,
it's a crazy experience,
man.
It's,
you feel like you have more of a chance to riff on stage and use to,
I don't know,
man.
I've been cutting my sets down,
talk an hour and 10 minutes and just
one podcast that re made me reevaluate everything I do on stage.
But 50 minutes,
someone said 50 minutes.
Jim Norton did that.
Norton good 50 I saw him do 50 in Austin and he made me think,
because I do a lot of who's doing a lot of long sets where I'd do this question
and answer thing at the end.
But the problem with a question unanswered thing is that it doesn't have the
same pop as the regular show.
And so the show always would kind of end on some weird note.
Like I'd be crushing for an hour and then I do this question answer thing for an
hour and then people would be tired.
So the,
the,
the experience of a show was not the same,
you know?
And I,
I thought it was just giving a more show.
I thought I was being more generous,
giving them more shell,
but I realized the best way to do it really is to give them an hour,
hour and 10 Max and just smash it.
Just come out of the gates gun.
I'm,
and I've been doing that for like
even getting standing o's,
those last,
all those shows in Portland.
I mean instead of like,
cause I saw it too.
It kind of like a fizzle.
It was,
it just kind of like shows over.
Now here's this other thing.
And then people forgot about the show.
There were kind of doing this and it was just,
but now it's just like fucking roaring.
You know?
Those people want to come back.
They're telling all their friends immediately instead of going,
oh yeah,
it was good last night.
Yeah,
they were all standing ovations.
It was,
it was awesome.
Portland was fucking awesome.
Never had a place where people handed me more.
We'd never,
dude,
I stunk of lead.
When I got home I was wearing the same pants that I wore,
the shy,
the show the night before and Mrs and was like,
you fucking stink like weed and that is my pants.
I took a shower and she was like,
it's still smell in the bathroom.
And then she goes,
your pants.
She goes,
what did you smoke your fucking pants?
Like they smelled like we,
it was ridiculous.
It was just from people blowing weed on me and Joey.
And then when we're in the green room,
Joe,
I remember when I kept on saying at the airport like I smell weed.
Who was my pants?
No,
I,
it might've been that too,
but it's going to probably open my book bag up and there was a bowl,
there was a joint in a bag of weed,
in a secret pocket I didn't even know existed.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit,
I would have
done,
I would pretend that I didn't know you and I would have ran the opposite
direction.
I need to go home and see my kids do it.
I can't be going to court for you one time or flying to Vegas that were in my
car or singing in my car and we have a bag of weed and he's like,
just bring it.
And I go,
I don't want to because I don't want to go through security with it.
And he's like,
it's fucking Vegas.
Do you think anyone's going to check the worst of the worst?
And so I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
So I thought my bag,
we go to leave,
we start walking at the last minute,
I fucking go,
oh,
hold
on.
And I,
I take it out of my bag,
I just throw it in the car and I go,
I'm not fucking bringing it.
I'm not bringing it.
So,
but I don't tell Jay,
I'm just like,
fuck it.
I'll deal with it when we get to Vegas.
So we go through security and as we go through security,
they pulled me to the side and then I start,
we're going to need to check your bag.
And Jay thinks,
yeah,
I have it.
And I start laughing hysterically because I know that I know I did.
He thinks I have it and to,
and then the guy is a tall black guy,
Jay staying right there.
He goes,
what are you laughing at,
sir?
And I go,
I almost traveled with weed,
but I left at my car and Jay goes,
you didn't bring it to my car.
And the guy was like,
you,
if we,
where's your car?
I was like,
I'm not going to tell you you have weed.
Where's your car and your car?
And I was like,
yeah,
but I'm not flying.
What kind of a TSA bullshit fucking question.
That's probably going on his break soon.
Yeah.
He wanted it.
He wanted to scare you and to give it up.
The week I got walked into Braves stadium and I said to the lady,
just had a curiosity.
So when the,
it's the moment that you don't have drugs that you want to find out how it would
go down if they busted you.
Right.
And I said to the lady,
I said,
she was checking my fanny pack when I firmly believe in fanny packs.
Fuck yeah.
Give me some knuckles on that ship.
Yeah.
Here's what was the,
I'm getting mad at all.
All of this.
What's dead for 2011 the fanny pack will never die.
Okay.
Because I'm not trying to get laid.
So fuck you.
They're so convenient.
They're writing.
They're all your shit's right there.
Exactly.
I love wearing them.
I love,
I love that people think they're dorky.
It's good.
Especially if you're married and have kids.
It's awesome.
You have more.
Before I was married with kids.
Kid.
How about I never stopped wearing it.
How about I wore that shit in the 90s you were giving me Shit on the message
board in the 90s for wearing a fanny pack.
If you're very successful and it doesn't matter,
Brian [inaudible] around to stop and think about the level of pussy that you get
on a regular basis.
If I was really good,
still rock a fanny pack and pull it off,
trust me kid.
They would probably get you more pussy who probably get you more pussy cause
he's like,
this is what the fuck I carries one a fanny pack.
I'm going to wear pink converse.
All stars.
Two women.
That's one of the things that women like more than anything is a guy that can be
himself.
That's what you should know is what the fuck you are.
Instead of you going out and pretending to be some different person,
no matter where the fuck you go,
women know when they can count on you.
They know when they can count.
Here's Ryan's going to be silly not to exactly go fucking porn style.
A big,
big fucking twisty one.
So there's a list of just got released talking about checking you at the airport
cause there's,
this is amazing.
It's the Department of Homeland Security and they put out this,
the the following characteristics a qualifies a person for it to potential
domestic terrorists.
And I put this shit on my Twitter because it's so ridiculous.
Expressions of libertarian philosophies,
bumper stickers or statements like you might be a fucking po potential domestic
terrorists because you think that people should be able to do whatever they want
to do.
You think that Libertarian ideology is better than Republican or Democratic
ideology?
Amazing.
You have a bumper sticker.
So you might be a domestic terrorist and this is,
if this was just some crazy asshole,
that ransom website.
So right.
Website.
But this
is like,
they're the like giving people instructions,
look out for second amendment oriented views and Ra or gun club membership.
Jesus fucking Christ.
What?
You can't go hunting.
If you,
if you,
if you want to eat,
you shoot your own mean instead of getting it from some fucking slaughterhouse,
you're a potential domestic terrorists because you believe in the rights that
to,
to keep guns.
You think that adults should be able to have guns?
Just like adults can have fucking cars.
Okay.
Just like adults can have a lot of shit that can fuck you up.
All right.
Yeah.
God,
people should have guns.
All right.
That's why they're here.
They're here.
So a,
you can shoot people that are bad and B,
you can shoot animals and eat them.
Okay.
It's not fucking potential terrorist issue.
So say there's out argue,
there's no connection between people who own guns and terrorism.
I don't know about that.
I would say almost 100% I mean,
the guy's a fucking flew planes into that 11 that's just cause they couldn't get
guns on board.
I mean,
if you want to check guns.
Exactly.
But what's the,
where's the connection?
Where do you draw connection between someone who owns a gods?
The idea is that people want to overthrow the government.
You know,
so thinking about their drinking,
what they're thinking about people who rise the fuck up and realize this God
damn corrupt government that's running this country needs to be held accountable
for all their bullshit.
I finally finished watching that inside job last night.
Fuck,
I had to turn off the last time I watched it,
I watched it for an hour and I'm like,
ah,
I'm getting angry for no reason and I had to shut it off,
but I,
I finally watched it all last night.
It is maddening.
It's all about the financial collapse.
It's not inside Java a year that you think nine 11 it's not about nine 11 it's
all about the financial collapse and it's all interviewing all these economists
and all these people that didn't predict it.
All these people that fucking profit from it.
And it talks about one of the most disturbing things is how corrupt economics
has become the study of economics at the university level.
Because all these fucking guys who are teaching economics at Harvard and at
Columbia,
they don't wind up working for the,
the presidents.
They all work wind up working for governments.
And they wind up going on these,
speaking to Kate engagements where they're making millions of dollars and they
showed this like how fucked it is that everyone is just stealing and everyone's
getting away with it because everyone is protecting everyone.
Everyone is making sure that no one is held accountable for all this fucking
incredible movie man in Matthew,
Matt,
Matt Damon,
uh,
Matthew Damon is a narrator and uh,
it's,
it's really good if you want to get crazy,
go and see how fucked up this country is and how fucked up the unfixable
foundation of this country is.
The Financial Foundation,
this country,
it's nuts.
It is amazing that it works at all.
And these motherfuckers that got bonuses,
man,
just the brazen assholeishness to ask for hundreds of millions of dollars during
the,
in the middle of the gigantic financial collapse you are at least partially
responsible for.
And the fact that nobody holds them to the fire,
it's nuts,
man.
It is one of the nuttiest documentaries I've ever seen in my life.
Wow.
This guy who was running the documentary too,
he's asking some of the questions.
One of the guys and he catches a lot of these guys.
Like one of the guys that worked for rob,
for Bush in a,
you know,
he was,
uh,
an economic advisor for Bush.
And he's also,
he did,
if he believe he teaches at Harvard and they caught this guy and they were
talking to them and ask them a question,
and you see the,
the frustration when they're hitting them with logic and facts and like,
how could you not know?
And then they're hitting him with all this information about things that he said
and how wrong it was.
And how did you,
why did you think that this economy was stable?
Why did you think that,
you know,
these,
uh,
funds should be,
you know,
rated at Aa.
Meanwhile,
they crashed the very next day.
I mean,
it's just nuts,
man.
They're just stealing.
It's,
it's incredible.
It's like everyone is stealing.
So it seems like they can get away with it and they can keep doing it.
No one's asking for anybody to be held accountable.
It's really weird,
man.
I mean we're in the middle of like a giant trillion dollar heist and these
bankers have literally ripped off everyone.
It's,
it's one of the most incredible things I think I've ever seen when and when it's
really explained in detail when they talk about it from the point of the stock
market and you know,
and w where people were banking on things to fail yet selling them and,
and,
and promoting them with their clients.
I mean,
wow.
It's amazing.
I mean you have to watch it like five or six times I think to really wrap your
head around how fucking complex at all is because the,
the whole financial system is,
it's almost intangible.
It's like it's,
there's nothing there.
Like as you get deeper and deeper into and try to figure,
you try to pick something up,
there's nothing to grab.
It's a really weird man.
It drives me fucking nuts.
If the movies,
any indication of this conversation,
I think I'd be lost within the five first five minutes.
Yeah,
I can.
I try to always have a six year olds to intelligent a tell it like a span of
listening to shit.
I'm know,
I'm just so,
I'm just so fucking frustrated.
Yeah,
pretty much
like as a kid,
did you read?
Yeah,
I never fucking red really never at first book I ever read was like really red,
like bought it for myself and said I'm going to read it was naked by a David
Sedaris.
Well I used to read,
um,
when I was a kid I used to read a lot of fiction and then I started doing
martial arts or read a lot of martial arts books,
you know,
really read a lot of books on strategy.
Like you know,
that's where I first read the book of five rings,
which became like,
uh,
it's,
this is the tattoo that I,
this is me and motor Musashi fighting a tiger.
And the reason,
one of the reasons why I got that tattoos,
cause I read something when I was a little kid that really sunk into my head.
Once you understand the way broadly you can see it in all things is what he
said.
And the idea is that once you find greatness in anything,
whether it's painting or sculpture or music,
when will you find some that you just nail it?
You,
you get to the core of it,
you understand what,
what greatness is and you can see it in everything.
You could see it,
not just in your chosen field but in everything.
And it really is like a,
a way of,
you know,
of channeling brilliance.
And it made me think that as I was a kid,
that if I just really threw myself into martial arts,
I could be successful at life because even if it wasn't martial arts that I
wound up pursuing,
there would,
I would,
if I could get greatness,
if I could really figure out what greatness is with,
I could really understand the way really tap into it,
I could transfer that onto to my life,
which has actually been true,
better at comedy or martial arts.
Uh,
I dunno man.
And,
and I've never even thought about it that it's not even something that I would
think about it.
It's all you.
You're better at whatever you put the most attention to.
No,
but good example.
The first time like I was a big baseball player growing up and I remember
playing baseball with guys that went on to go pro.
I caught Brad Radke,
uh,
who was a pitcher for the twins and I remember playing baseball with them all
grown up in the way that parents looked at him playing baseball.
I remember thinking like,
no one looks at me like that.
No one is like pulling me aside.
Like,
Hey,
great cabernet pert like are still made all stars.
And I still got recruited to play like at a high school,
but I never had the,
I never had that it,
that.
And then the first time I did standup I was like,
okay,
that's the like I got that it,
this is what is the similarity
for me,
it's probably just the opposite really am.
When I first started doing comedy and I was leaving martial arts,
I was really good at martial arts and not good at comedy at all.
And I had to reinvent myself because as a,
as a martial artist,
I was,
you know,
for time,
Massachusetts state taekwondo champion,
I won the US Open.
I,
I came in second place in the u s cop to the current national champion in front
in the Olympics.
And I was right there and I was really young.
I was 20,
19 at the time.
And then 21,
uh,
I had a couple of fights.
I started kickboxing when I was 21.
That's what fucked up everything.
And that's one of the reasons why I stopped doing,
I stopped competing is cause I started realizing that there was a bunch of holes
in my martial arts game because I was just doing one style of,
of,
of martial art,
which was taekwondo.
And when I switched from taekwondo to boxing and kickboxing,
I realize he's just big holes in my game.
And then so then it made me not respect taekwondo as much as an individual
martial art.
And then competing in taekwondo seem sort of ridiculous to me because,
well now I know that,
you know,
I'm vulnerable to punches.
So now in my mind I would have to start kickboxing because otherwise I would be
practicing something that wasn't as effective.
So then I started kickboxing and I realized,
okay,
there's not even any money in this.
What the fuck am I doing here?
What am I going to do?
I'm going to run a kickboxing gym and you know,
I'm going to have brain damage.
I mean that I was looking at my future and I was like,
I figured I've got to figure out what the fuck I'm doing here.
I was 21 and I was,
she's doing comedy at the same time.
Don't have that kind of insight at 21 keep going.
Well was big mostly because no one raised me left in the streets like a wolf.
I mean,
my parents both worked and by the time you know,
they got home,
it was six o'clock and you know,
I was over at a friend's house or something and was a wild kid.
It was your own laundry.
Yeah.
Was it,
was it?
Yeah,
it was a different time,
man.
You know,
when I was little man,
I was like seven years old.
I used to do a fisherman's wharf.
I used to in San Francisco,
used to have my own magic show.
I used to walk down the street by myself with my own thing.
I was thinking was a seven or eight and I had like a little magic show that I
got for Christmas and I would put a fucking hat on and a cape and I'd set up a
stand that I would do a show by myself,
no friends and no one with me completely by myself.
This is a different world.
You know the people lived in back then.
You can't let a fucking eight year old out of the house by themselves today.
That kid's going to get raped and killed.
Too bad you didn't know little Joey Diaz at the,
I know.
I wish that for you.
Why you buddies?
We're going to have a fucking awesome show.
Joey and I would have been best friends from the moment we met.
I was best friends with Joey the moment I met him.
I would have been best friends with Joey if we met when we were six [inaudible]
two.
So I realized I thrown my whole life into martial arts from the time I was 15
until I was 21.
But when I was 20,
I started teaching at this place in revere.
There was a nautilus fitness place in revere and uh,
they had a,
a big extra side room.
It's really big,
nice room.
So we started teaching taekwondo there and her,
I opened my own branch of the Jay Kim Taekwondo and stood out there and that's
where I met this guy,
Joe Lake,
who was a boxing coach and he's coached up some UFC guys like Marcus Davis.
And he's uh,
you know,
it was really,
really good boxing coach and a great guy.
And it became one of my good friends and he taught me how to box.
And when I started boxing I started realizing like,
man,
I've got like all these holes in my fucking martial arts game.
Like at Taekwondo.
I was really good at taekwondo,
but you added in boxing and then eventually leg kicks.
And I'm like,
man,
I got a lot of fucking flaws in my game.
So it made me not want to ever compete in taekwondo again.
And then since it was so much work to do to become a competent kickboxer and
then it was like,
well,
what am I going to do?
Become a boxer?
Because if I become a boxer now,
I'm really starting almost from scratch.
I mean I'm a rudimentary,
almost a,
you know,
begin or boxer and then I'm going to,
what am I going to start fighting in that way because that's the only place I
can get fights because you couldn't even get boxing or kickboxing fights in
Massachusetts.
We had to drive to Rhode Island to fight.
So the last time I fought,
I fought three times in one day I find a kickboxing tournament.
I won the first fight,
I knocked the first guy out,
I beat the second guy up,
and then the third guy dock me out.
Third Guy,
it was like three fights and I was completely exhausted.
It's hours later,
this is all for free.
And I got it.
Was door won the first round and then I got clipped with a left hook and it was
really weird because it didn't even hurt.
It's just my legs stop working.
It was never happened to me before.
And I find is that the ones where they go like this,
they go,
just go rubber boy and I only,
I need to just stop working.
It's like he disconnected my,
my brain from my legs,
my legs no longer communicated with my brain.
They just shut off.
And I went down and I got up and then he hit me again.
I went down again,
I got up and they stopped the fight.
It was a,
wasn't,
I've been hit way harder before.
It wasn't that he just hit me perfect,
perfect spot.
And I was exhausted.
You know,
when you're,
I had shitty nutrition and I was delivering newspapers.
I'd get up every morning and five o'clock to deliver newspapers and then I
would,
you know,
take a nap and then I would drive limos and then I would go train.
And then I was still trying to do comedy at the same time.
So that made me really realize I had to pick a path and I'm like,
you know,
this was a good wake up call for me and my ego wanted me to get back in there
and go smash and you know,
show that it was a bad,
you know,
that I really,
I didn't train ride for that fight and I was out of shape and I was sick,
you know.
But I thankfully figured out a way to shut my ego up long enough to get some
distance.
Your Ego's fudge goes fucked.
In what way?
It's a test to shit.
That doesn't matter.
Like what way?
I don't know.
I'm starting to see the word a little differently.
Um,
recently last conversation had I
had said something about,
I almost got to have a talk about almost getting into a fight with the guy or in
driving,
remember?
Yes.
And you were like,
that's fucking out of it.
The dumbest thing in the world.
And that to me was the first wake up call of like,
yeah,
why would I do that?
Like I started thinking like the guy,
Felix,
just from our conversation,
you started thinking about,
oh,
are you?
Yeah,
fuck him.
Actually fairly heavily.
You're probably one of our,
I mean this,
you wouldn't want to hear this,
but like probably one of the toughest guys I know.
Uh,
like stuff,
like no one would ever scare you or you still have people scare me,
but I know,
but,
but I'm constantly around.
People scare me.
But what I'm saying,
it's like,
and so I started like,
uh,
checking like,
okay,
why do you feel so confident to start fights with people?
And then I started and then it started like sizzling down and it was like,
holy shit man.
My Ego,
my ego is totally attached to,
to,
to not like cool shit.
Like it's not,
I,
it's not attached to my,
I don't know.
I don't even know what an ego should be attached to.
Do you have parts of your personality that bother you?
Oh,
every part of my personality.
Okay.
Well what do you do about that?
Nothing.
I drink.
What did you do it?
You supposed to do something.
I meditate and I get in the tank.
No,
I trust the,
my number one thing I drink and then forget about it and then wake up and I just
fucking a tank man.
I think you'd really enjoy it.
I would want you to next to me and I'd want,
I've had the sense that we can talk to each other.
You can do it at my house,
Bro.
And I could be right outside of the tank.
There's parts of my personality.
I can't stand.
I,
you know what,
why don't you tell me what you know.
I don't like this,
but don't be sensitive.
Okay.
Well,
okay,
but listen,
I love you man.
You don't have to worry about,
no,
I know.
Um,
I,
uh,
I am,
I like,
I know that when this shit,
when birth conquer gets canceled,
whenever it does get canceled,
I will talk about it incessantly to people.
No,
you want,
I will use this.
This is what you say.
You say you'll talk about it,
which is why you'll talk about it.
But if you just say you want and just decide,
you know what,
when birth to conquer,
if it ever does get cancelled,
God forbid I'm going to move on to something else and I'm going to,
I'm going to push forward.
You're an entertaining guy man.
The world needs entertaining people part.
You don't have to worry about that.
Do you not like about you?
I get angry at things too easily or seriously.
I do that too.
Something I know about my number one,
my number one thing,
whether it's something someone says or something,
something that happens or even watching this fucking,
this documentary,
I get angry.
I was like visualizing what I wanted to do physically to each one of these cons
that's causing all these people who lose their houses and I'm just picturing
myself strangling them and just getting so enraged and it almost becomes like an
animal like animalistic,
primal.
It gets very,
it's very dangerous and that's why I was saying to you like,
be really careful man,
cause you never know who the fuck are you going to run across.
It's crazy as I might be.
I'm nothing compared to a lot of people that I've ever met.
Man,
I've,
I've met some really crazy motherfuckers that if you pick them,
you're the wrong guy and you wind up saying something to them.
They like,
oh,
thank you Jesus.
You've just brought me someone to kill,
you know,
and they'll attack you and they know how to fight too.
There's a lot of people like that.
A lot of them I've met a lot of you always been like that.
Me Anger.
Yeah.
Part of it is my childhood,
part of it is genetic.
I have Sicilian peasant genes.
I mean,
these are the reason why my hands are,
is widest cinder blocks.
You know,
I have the weirdest Bulger let folks,
I've got the weirdest bone structure ever.
I've giant hands,
you know,
they're,
they're good for hitting things.
I'm short and wide.
My family,
you know,
they grew up carrying bricks and shit,
that's what my ancestors did.
You know,
that,
that like that design.
I think there's a lot of aggression built into certain body types.
And I think there's,
you know,
if you look at like super athletic,
like you know,
you look at some fucking like,
you know some Mike Tyson looking dude,
like look at Mike Tyson,
just body,
you look desk.
God it looks like he's designed to destroy things.
Just designed to like when he used to step into the ring,
when he was in the prime of his life in the late eighties he would get into that
fucking ring and it was like that is the scariest human being that's ever walked
the face of the earth.
You couldn't imagine doing anything else.
That's what he was there for.
He's there just smash things.
Just the tank.
Yeah,
that guy guaranteed he's got a giant biological buildup of stress that he's
needs to blow up besides having a fucked up childhood.
I mean I think a lot of people that are in jail are in jail because they have
fucked up bodies,
man.
They have fucked up childhoods a
interesting.
So you can almost say that the,
the body dictates a personality
does have some effect.
It's not a completely,
it's not a completely benign thing.
I think without a doubt.
You look my,
I think so much clearer after I work out.
To me it's like mandatory.
I don't,
I don't allow myself to say,
Oh fuck,
I'm tired.
Let me just take a nap.
I don't allow that because I don't like me when I don't work out,
so I'm making me work out and make me work out so I can,
I can be saying like,
it's for me,
it's like I,
I always feel like I got this monkey and a funnel.
Let this monkey,
yeah,
the cage.
He's going to throw shit at me and he's going to fucking start rattling the
cage.
Lighting things on fire.
Just let them out of the cage.
Come on buddy.
Let's go.
It's the same way I feel like about my dogs.
Like I feel bad if I don't walk my dogs.
If I don't take him around the neighborhood,
let 'em go smell it.
I want him to get out.
Let's get out.
It's come out.
It's the same thing with the animal inside you.
The animal side.
You need though,
did that mother fucker needs to rage and if it doesn't rain starts looking for
opportunities to rage.
I started looking at me this dick once to get my lane.
Fuck you.
Fuck you bitch.
After I work out,
I'm like,
yeah,
go ahead dude.
I'm not in a rush.
I started letting people,
I thought of this the other day.
I got flipped off by these very liberal couple,
really a very liberal couple.
Of course I am the stereotype of,
of ignorant white male.
Like I drive a fricking expedition expedition black on black,
you know,
fucking,
I'm just going to tap out sticker in your back.
I can get you one.
I'll put it
something like hip hop.
And I,
and I,
I guess I cut them off.
I don't even know.
And they were in a little,
uh,
what's the Little Prius though?
The Smart car.
The tiny Cooper from mini Cooper and they flicked me off and then she went up
and went,
ah,
like was thumbing up in me and pointing at me.
Oh yeah.
I don't know me or my car,
who fucking knows.
And,
uh,
and then I was,
we both got off at Laurel Canyon and we're right next to each other.
And I was like,
I'm gonna fucking tell him off.
And then I was like,
hold on.
If I tell him off,
nothing's going to come to this.
But if I make them feel like they won,
then maybe they'll continue this behavior until they run into the guy who beats
the living fuck out of them.
And you set a trap.
So I set a trap and I rolled down the window and I was like,
you guys let me fuck,
fuck.
And then they took off and they laughed and I was like,
great.
Just keep it up.
Keep it up.
You took a dive dive sitting going to fucking off
genius.
That's,
I've never heard anyone doing that.
No.
Do you see,
do you sense phoniness and people right out the gate?
Oh,
I'm so fucking good at that because you're so honest.
Aw Fuck.
I'm really honest with my bullshit.
I see shit like right out the gate and I'm like,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm super honest.
So when someone's not being honest,
I smell it a mile away.
I smell crazy too.
Crazy and dangerous.
Yeah.
My wife's best friend,
we went out to dinner with them and uh,
when we first met him and I fuck him,
you know me,
I'll talk all night long and drink and we're having a good time.
And then we got done.
I don't fucking like them.
And she was like,
how can you not like them?
You just had a time ago.
She's fucking crazy.
She was like,
she's not crazy.
And then,
and then,
and then now I'm like Matlock.
I'm like,
if we just got to hang it on enough and then I got to just untangle the necklace
enough,
it just starts to fall apart.
And I'm like,
and then I brought it up one time about like drugs and she was like,
oh,
I used to have a problem with math and I was like,
failure.
Dude.
That's so funny you said that.
I had a Brian Cowen story where Brian used to always date these really fucked up
girls and try to fix them.
And Brian's been one of my best friends since [inaudible] 94 when I hosted mad
TV,
I met Brian and we'd like instantly became best friends when we're hanging
around.
The first thing I noticed when we're hanging around together,
it's like this motherfucker date some broken pitches.
I mean his current wife is a very nice person,
but his,
his,
he's had some disasters in his past.
He Fuck Fiona apple a no comment.
Okay.
I just remember hearing something about no car comment.
No comment.
Um,
we are on the Internet.
There's hundreds of thousands of people and some of them may know Fiona,
so probably not.
Anyway,
um,
he,
uh,
he just,
you know,
I used to tell him,
man,
you got to get better at reading people.
Like,
again,
I'm getting it.
I'm getting better,
man.
This new girl,
you're going to love her.
You're gonna love her.
So he introduces me to her,
right?
I say,
hi,
how are you doing?
She goes,
hi,
nice to meet Ya.
And then I go,
can I talk to you for a second?
I pull them outside.
I go,
listen to me,
man.
She is fucking crazy.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
I go do this bitch is fucking
no.
I shook the hand.
I shook her hand and I looked in their eyes and I saw madness.
It was like that Sam Shepard movie based on that,
uh,
in the mouth of madness.
Remember that?
It was like that.
I was like,
this bitch is completely insane.
so I pulled them aside and go,
this shouldn't me round.
I called.
That bitch is crazy.
She's a night.
No,
no.
She's a good girl.
No,
no,
no.
Dude.
She's a fucking hammer to do.
Do,
do,
do.
You're famous.
She's nervous.
She's meeting.
No,
no,
no.
It has nothing to do with that.
I got that bitch is crazy,
man.
You got to trust me,
dude.
I know.
Crazy.
All my spider senses,
we're going off.
I go,
you better get the fuck away from that girl.
Trust me.
You're going to find out.
You're gonna to find out the hard way you need to run.
Like what do you track through?
But she's nice.
She's needs friends.
No,
no,
no.
She does not.
Does she need threats?
Fucking nut.
Okay.
Time goes on and eventually he finds out that she's a method,
like a massive,
you know,
I don't know how he missed this,
but like she was completely insane and I had some,
like some guy was looking at looking for her and you know,
anyway,
he winds up eventually slowly getting rid of her.
Right.
It just gets rid of her.
And then one day he's walking down the street.
Okay.
And he sees his girl walking towards him and the girls are hooker.
You know,
she's got a skirt on and he looks up,
me,
realizes it's this girl and she's got fucking scabs on her face.
Like she's picking her face.
Yeah.
And he goes,
uh,
how's it gone?
She goes,
what do you think?
Okay,
you take care of me.
This is all,
and I,
and I swear to God,
I picked this up from,
hi,
how are you?
I was like,
what?
All these alarms,
I'm good at that.
I can be not,
you can't,
you cannot always think you're good at that.
You always got to be open to the possibility that you haven't picked it up yet.
He goes gotta be open to the possibility.
Some people are better at covering their bullshit or they have different
motivations for being crazy.
You know what?
What is their motivator there or they're delusional.
Crazy cause delusional.
Crazy is pretty easy to spot because they lie to themselves or are they
deceptive?
Crazy.
Deceptive.
Strange because sometimes deceptive.
Crazy.
I just like a sociopathic element of it where they're not concerned about how
they come off so that they'll like,
they'll like really like play to your strengths and all of a sudden you like
this kind of,
it really complements me.
Wow.
We like meanwhile,
but he is is just a certain type of manipulative crazy that you haven't picked
up yet.
Oh,
I've had so many crazy people in my life.
Of course.
You're a comic man.
I mean dude doing just doing shows.
How many nutty fucking people do you mean after shows?
She made the greatest sounds man,
you could crack me up every time.
So listen,
man,
last time you were here,
there's a fucking story about the Russian mob.
We tease these bitches.
We let these people right now on Twitter,
they have been going crazy all day.
Do not let Bert Kreischer get out of there without the Russian mob story,
man.
Tell us what the fuck happened.
All right,
this is in 1993 probably I think is what I went to Russia.
I was taking Russian classes at Florida state.
I thought they were Spanish classes because I thought there has been as glasses
because I,
it was a noon class and I signed up and then I was like fucking sweet Spanish at
noon.
I could phone that in.
And then I get there and they start writing a new language,
a new alphabet.
And I'm like,
all right,
this clearly isn't Spanish.
So then I said,
I'm going to leave.
And the teacher's like,
listen,
don't leave.
Um,
because if you leave,
we can't have a class and I can't get my master's degree.
So,
but if you stick around,
I'll talk to you after the class.
I get done the end of the class.
She's like,
listen,
don't,
uh,
you know,
if you don't leave and I won't just show up at class,
I'll give you a c.
I was like done,
done.
So I took Russian,
I took Russian one,
two and three because these kids need it.
Another guy in the class to take these classes.
So then finally I take rush.
I'd take words from form and we go to Russia,
we go to Russia.
But this is Russia.
Like when the mob ran Russia,
like are you,
are you guys aware of that?
Okay.
In like the nine,
late nineties,
mid nineties the mob ran everything that had to do with Russia.
So when going over to Russia,
you had to,
you had to literally pay off the mob in order to go and study abroad.
So we paid off the mob and they gave us in return to banditos too young mobsters
who would go everywhere with us.
They lived in our hotel,
they stayed with us,
they went on tours with us.
They weren't,
they were did everything with us.
Their names are eager and Sasha and when we got our,
our teacher was like,
listen,
this is Igor and Sasha.
They will be ghosting us with my teacher who was there with me.
It was like during the fucking mob,
Igor,
inside you go inside and they were guy named Bruce and they were like,
and they were,
oh,
it gets worse.
So they like,
listen,
whatever you do to our class,
do not talk to them.
Do not interact with them.
Do not engage them.
They're only here to shadow us.
So in my head I'm like,
fucking get to know these guys.
Right?
Like get a bottle of vodka,
a six pack of Baal to go knock on their door.
No,
mind you,
I speak no Russian at the time,
no rushing because I'd never studied none of the classes.
So first night there and knock on Igor and Sasha's room and they're having a
party in there and like fucking all their friends are in their room.
They lived right next to me and Kendra,
my teacher lived across the hall from Igor,
so knock on their door.
Igor opens the door and he looks like a fucking thug.
He's got,
he's got like a wife beater on a cigarette of beer and he just looks at me in
Russia and just goes stall.
And now as the second he says that I start panicking.
All the phrases I had in my head that I was trying to say all disappear.
And all I say to Igor in Russian is I am the machine and what does that he say
that,
you know?
And so,
but I just said,
yeah going I seeing though.
And he went stole and now I don't know what I said.
I'm like,
did it,
what did I just say?
I'll fuck you up.
Like,
and I go,
I go,
I am the machine.
And he goes,
say it again.
I said,
I haven't let me scene.
And then he starts laughing and he brings me into the room and he's like,
hold on,
say it again.
And so I say it to the room,
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
I'm like,
I'm the machine.
And they're like,
you're the big,
I'm like on the machine.
I said that all fucking night with these guys.
That's the more communication we had.
As I said on the machine,
and Igor and Sasha and I became best friends,
right?
We did everything together.
If we went on a field trip,
they would tell me,
machine,
you don't need to go on the field trips.
Come drink with us.
So now,
uh,
cut to one day,
we have to take a train to Moscow.
No different mob.
Ran The train to Moscow and a driftwood Tro,
tro Marbury and Moscow and Igor,
Sasha.
We're not allowed to cross boundaries and it's all me.
They said,
listen,
we're not going to go with you,
but we've taken care of you.
We've talked to the mobsters on the train and in Moscow because we had to pay
them too.
They had,
they weren't allowed to come with you.
There weren't allowed to come with us.
And we're paying a different mob now to protect us on the train or pick a
different mob to protect us in Moscow.
Holy Shit.
So they said,
we've taken care of it.
Don't worry about it.
So they take me to the train.
And,
uh,
they introduced me to our tune.
Who?
Gangsters?
Igor and Igor.
Igor.
And there's not a lot of names in Russia.
It's Alex,
Igor or Sascha.
What about fuel?
So,
so Igor,
Igor,
Igor said,
so these are yours.
This is the machine.
If you give them alcohol,
you'll have a great time.
So even Negro,
like through the roof,
they're like,
awesome,
don't worry,
we've taken care of you.
We were sitting in first class,
you're not sitting with your class,
you're sitting in first class to Moscow.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this is what I'm talking about.
And I bring another guy,
John Bolshoi big John.
I bring him with me to go sit in first class.
And sure enough,
man,
we were fucking FirstClass just meet these two.
Igor is John the conductor?
I shit you not the conductor before the train takes off,
comes into the room.
I swear to you,
rips off the band on this thing says this is a present for the machine.
It would be an honor to do a shot with you.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
this is fucking right.
So I do a shot with its conductor and we pound this vodka within like fucking
30,
45 minutes.
We're done all the vodka in the room.
Whoa.
We're drinking hard.
And my classes all in coach and I'm sitting in first class and even or Negro or
like,
let's go get more vodka.
And I'm like,
done.
They,
these guys run the fucking train.
So we get up,
we walk into the bar cart and a biggie or says machine,
grab a bottle of uh,
grab,
grab some bread club.
And I'm like,
that's bread.
I'm understanding Rochelle.
He's like,
grab some,
see it,
this cheese.
I'm like,
I'm learning Russian.
I'm looking at,
John is standing behind me.
He's like,
Eh,
he's a vodka.
I go,
I know that one.
And he's like,
grab all the money,
grab all the approvals.
And I go,
what?
I look around and were robbing the bar cart.
What the,
the bartender standing like this.
Everyone's standing against the wall and I'm sitting behind the bar with a
handful of rubles,
a bottle of vodka and a thing of bread going,
holy fuck.
John looks at me.
And he's like,
just take it,
let's go take all the fucking cash out of the bar cart,
not making eye contact every,
and they're papillon just lets it happen.
It's the mob.
They ran everything in Russia,
everything.
Wow.
And so we get done and we'd go back to our room and it's a totally different
energy,
like very like very sketchy,
you know.
And he freaked out.
Now I'm free talks.
I'm like,
fuck,
I just robbed the car like no one else saw anyone rubbed.
The bark are except for me.
And my teacher,
Val,
who's at the time was our chaperone,
didn't speak any Russian.
She comes to our first class cart,
opens the door and says,
I need to talk to you right now.
And I was like,
listen.
And she goes,
I told you that you're in big trouble.
You I my classmate,
your classmates that told me what happened.
Big Ego.
It takes a sip of vodka,
spits in her eyes and goes,
no one talks to the machine like that.
I'm like,
whoa.
He spit vodka in her eyes,
fucking it is and then shuts the door.
And then it looks at me and he says,
don't worry,
I got you.
When it gets dark,
we're going to have a lot of fun.
And he pulls out a thing,
a keys.
He's got keys to the whole fucking train.
He's like,
we're going to rob everyone when the,
when it gets dark now I'm like,
fuck,
why did I get myself into like,
this is bad news,
bad fucking news.
So we get stark and sure enough,
then we start robbing the train,
go through my class first and we'd fucking open the door.
Little legal would crawl in,
pull the bags out.
John and I would go through them and try not to steal like anything important
and Biggie or would stand guard.
And if anyone woke up,
I mean take us civil vodka and spit it in their face.
And it was,
I mean,
it's sketchy now.
It's sketchy.
It's not even fun.
These guys aren't fucking,
no,
no.
They're loaded though.
They're hammered.
Piss drunk.
We robbed my whole class.
And then,
uh,
and then we end up,
they end up taking off and going into the car.
And me and John were sitting in,
in the first class,
courteous thing thinking,
we're fucked,
man.
We're fucked.
We robbed the train.
We probed the bar cart and they'd come back and they're just fucking angry,
drunk,
like Piss,
angry drunk.
We pull into Moscow and my teacher,
Val,
uh,
comes to the door,
opens it and said,
I'm just letting you know,
we've called the police.
So I was like,
fuck.
So Igor,
Igor,
like,
fuck it.
Don't worry.
Fuck the police.
This is Russia.
Who the fuck she thinks she is?
This isn't America.
This is Russia.
We run everything.
I'm like,
Ugh,
I'm going to fucking go to the gulag.
Sure enough.
Sure enough,
man,
the cops are sitting on the,
on the middle,
like the middle,
you know,
were people get off the train,
that little receiving area.
My class is sitting there,
my whole class or in the pajamas,
they're crying.
Their bags had been gone through their fucking giving statements to the cops and
the cops are writing them down and I'm sitting with Igor and eager and John in
the fucking car and they're just still drinking.
And smoking and they're like,
fuck this,
fuck,
this will take you there of this right now they walk outside out to the cops and
start yelling at the cops and I'm like,
mother Fucker,
this is not how I would have taken care of this.
I don't know.
I don't even know what they're saying.
But they're just shouting and the cops are shouting back and then finally biggie
or just starts pointing at me and I'm like,
oh,
he's been in this whole fucking thing on me.
Like I'm going down for the whole thing.
And then the cop starts pointing at me and telling me exists as it.
Yeah,
it's by the owner or whatever he's saying,
come here right now.
So I fucking walk out.
And it's that moment where you find the hash on your body,
you know they find it and you're going to jail forever.
Is that that moment that walk we were asshole gets cold and you're like,
this is,
it is an express fucking that's the moment.
And I walk all the way across this little fucking trail to get to him.
I get right up to the cop and the cop looks at me and he goes,
I understand you're the machine.
And I was like,
yeah,
and he goes,
tonight,
you party with us.
So then we went out and partied with these cops.
So the cops did nothing.
Fucking nothing.
They were so excited to meet the machine.
What?
They were like this fucking,
it was the,
it was,
it has,
it was a nickname.
No one funny in Russia.
Is that what it is?
No,
there was no,
there was no humor.
There was no with you.
Is that what it is?
Is this and no one funny.
And then you come along and you're hilarious.
So they're like,
we're partying with you.
Yeah.
And I was,
and I was just loud,
like there's not a lot of loud people like you.
Would you be willing to move to Russia to be their bitch and do like,
Nah,
dude,
those guys scared me one night,
the guy,
did you party with these guys?
Oh,
I partied with eagle or you were on the train only.
And then I partied with the cops in Moscow with John and then for one night and
then we hid from them cause they want it.
They like the cops one.
Uh,
no,
the cops were skipped were scary.
More scary than the gangsters because they,
you,
they could not get in trouble.
Like they either were like crying my cop car and you're like,
what the fuck drive my comp costs.
Fucking do they drive on the left side,
the right side,
same side as us.
I don't remember.
I was there for three months.
You'd think I'd know.
I have no idea.
I was drunk on the same side as us.
But they,
but they,
I mean like the whole experience in Russia was just,
it was just,
I remember one time we,
Igor and eat,
you're going to,
Sasha had said they were going to get a boat for us for Russian May Day or Labor
Day and they're like,
yeah,
we got to,
um,
they're going to have a big boat for our whole class.
We're all going out in the boat.
So I get up early for the day,
we're going out the boat and I go over to Igor his room and Igor is eating dried
fish,
drinking beers.
And I was like,
what's matter?
And he's like,
I'm fucked.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
we got no boat.
Like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I've,
I've tried everything to try to get a boat.
I can't get a fucking boat.
And we've promised the class of boat for the tour is supposed to have a boat.
And so we're like,
oh fuck.
And he goes,
and then all the sudden the phone rings and he goes,
we got a boat.
I go,
we do.
And he goes,
yeah.
So we start walking to the dock,
we're carrying a fucking big case of beer,
my whole class cameras and fucking little passports around their neck.
And one of his buddies just walks up and he's like,
hey.
And he's like,
And then we just get to the dock and there's a boat there and we just get on it
and take off.
And halfway through we realize like,
I just stole the fucking boat.
He just stole the boat and he was like,
Russia must be just fucking crazy.
Insane.
We went to,
went to a big mob boss party one night and he was like,
tells them my boss.
He goes,
this is the machine.
This is the guy I was telling about.
How does this all happen?
It just was loud and then,
and then I was partying with Eagle and Sasha so much that like that.
And they just tell their friends,
oh,
you gotta meet this guy,
you gotta meet this guy.
He's so funny.
We're going to have to drink with you and then moved it down.
We're going to do shots with [inaudible].
You gotta be careful,
man.
You were selling yourself as this incredible fun party guy and everyone's going
to want to do shots with you.
Oh,
I don't.
I'm,
I'm fucking,
are you friends with Igor on Facebook now?
Have these.
I tried to find them and I'm thinking,
where are you on Twitter?
I think ego wanting to be a filmmaker.
Really bad.
Like he really wanted to be a filmmaker and he talked about film and what kind
of film.
I have no fire.
I was 22 at the time.
Igor was ego is probably dead.
I would say you,
you had a pretty interesting life before you ever became a comedian.
You would think you have a wealth to fucking stuff to talk about on stage.
Did you ever figure out a way to tell that mobster story on stage?
I can't because it's too long.
It's too like it's,
I can tell you here,
but it to tell it to chop it up.
It's hard.
It's really hard.
It's like the Tracy Morgan Story.
I can't,
I never felt comfortable telling them.
That's ridiculous.
Well there's a perfect example cause look Jay was telling them on stage and it
was crushing.
Yeah,
I know.
Totally tell that onstage and maybe I'll have him tell the machine story and
then tighten it back from him.
Tighten it up.
Yeah,
just it just farm it out to other like,
you know,
if there is some Mexican comics in town,
sort of like Sarah get jokes.
You can have them carry your joke for you and to term.
But yeah,
so I don't,
I don't,
I don't party like that really anymore.
[inaudible] telling us how much hammered to get lately because you're trying to
avoid this plane's.
Yeah,
that's fucking anxiety.
That's me trying to handle whatever I've done to my brain so that I can get from
fucking La to New York.
Do you feel like you're,
some guys don't want to lose that anxiety because they're worried that if they
become evolved some whatever,
you know enlightened,
however you want to say that there wouldn't be funny anymore.
Yeah.
I'm afraid.
Whatever I get nervous is shipped.
Fargo stays still.
I used to think that a,
if I became more enlightened I wouldn't be funny.
I would avoid like doing yoga and I would avoid meditating because I literally
thought I had to be more fucked up to be funny.
I feel that way.
Like they asked me to get on this drug called Selectsa.
For what?
What does that do?
Share social anxiety disorder,
let's say.
So Alexa,
how you spell it?
S.
A.
Clec.
I want to say it's an S.
I got a prescription for it,
but I used to treat depression,
class of antidepressants called selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
and it works.
It increasing the amount of Serotonin,
a natural substance.
You know,
my thing with all this stuff is first get your body in order.
This is what I tell everybody whenever I talked to anybody and they're like,
oh,
I'm thinking about getting on something.
I'm not completely opposed to people doing any,
any sort of antidepressant.
I know people that's changed their fucking life.
I know people where it's helped them dramatically.
You know,
including one buddy of mine who got on it,
changes life and then slowly weaned himself off of it and literally has a
different way of thinking now.
And it saved him.
Yeah,
he was really super depressed.
He had some real issues.
You know,
how much,
how much of it was his childhood,
how much of it it was,
as you know,
biology,
whatever the fuck it is.
But I think you got to get your body in order before you start fucking around
with all that stuff.
My body's a wreck.
Yeah.
Well of course it's not working so good then.
So it's how often you work out.
Ah,
do you want to be healthy?
I mean,
what advice do you want advice?
Why don't you,
uh,
join some sort of a,
a gym,
get,
get some sort of a trainer.
That's when's that ever going to have?
Okay.
How about this?
Bring a DVD on the road with you.
I have DVDs that are all body weight exercises.
You can do it in your hotel room.
You set a laptop down on the bed and right in front of the bed you need a
fucking small space.
You start doing Hindu squats and Hindu pushups and you know,
shake weight and uh,
you know,
pushups with claps in between them.
And then you could do handstands against the wall.
Dude,
you can have a serious fucking workout.
Steve Maxwell told me how to do chin ups on a adore.
You,
uh,
you,
you put a towel inside the door,
slam it shut.
So there's a knot in the towel and then not stays like so that you know you can,
you can slam the door shut and you can have it like,
so you can't pull the towel.
Thrilled.
And then you do chin ups with it.
I do all kinds of crazy shit in my hotel room.
Yeah,
I'm sure that's one of the things I need to do.
Uh,
but before you start taking any crazy,
and they just said that's what you should be on.
Who says this fucking doctor?
I went to a therapist once and she was like,
you need to talk to,
cause I,
you know,
I have probably fly and I've always had a problem with falling and a flight
200,000 miles a year,
but I still
have anxiety when I get on a plane.
I can't get rid of it.
I just hasn't disappeared until they're like,
Yo,
it's,
you need to get on select,
sir.
You also have a social anxiety disorder.
And I'm like,
oh,
fuck it.
I can talk to people all day long.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous that anyone would say that you have a social anxiety disorder.
You're a fucking comedian,
but yeah,
but,
but it's,
I don't know.
So I'm sure there's a ton of things I need to do to fix my,
everyone has a little bit of social anxiety just cause you don't know.
I mean when you first talked to someone,
you don't know what the fuck you getting.
I you get better at it and more used to it as you get older.
But I used to remember I used to go to banks and uh,
so I had already started doing comedy at the time and uh,
I would fucking have weird almost um,
like,
like failures of my speech when I was talked to someone at the bank.
You know what I mean?
I'd get up to the counter.
Can I help you sir?
As a,
um,
yeah,
cause I need to,
I'd need to did Dodd deposit positives.
Like it was just like,
it just couldn't come out.
Right.
I was nervous for whatever stupid reason.
I mean,
I had fought,
I had done stand up,
I'd done all these scary,
scary things,
but talking to the teller for whatever reason,
you know,
it would make me walk up,
you know?
So I think we all have a certain amount of social anxiety.
It's just a matter of overcoming that need.
India,
Endeca,
Bert,
I've gotten so confused with whatever,
Endeca or whichever,
like what?
Every time I ever a conversation with someone,
they're like,
oh,
you need the one that doesn't make you think right?
Well you weren't the one that does it.
Make your body,
you don't want to feel in your body.
And I'm like,
oh,
it seems like that you're overthinking everything so that it seems like the,
I don't think it's any different than anyone else.
I don't think I'm,
I,
I think if anyone had in my life style or my life,
like when you travel,
you're gone all the time.
You're jumping off buildings,
you jumping out of planes.
Right.
I think if anyone had my life,
they'd go through this shit just has a noticeably change since you started doing
this show.
It's gotten much better.
Last year it was really bad,
but I've gotten much better with my anxiety.
Like now I can appreciate things and go,
wow,
this is really cool that I'm getting to do this.
Like last year I was just a fucking wreck.
I would find,
I would find injury and the smallest thing I'd be like,
that's going to,
I'm going to be doing a belly flop contest,
and I was like,
what if there's like a stick?
I mean it's going to fucking impale myself on.
It took a good question.
Should we look out for sticks?
Thank you.
Everyone was like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
You're going to break it?
And I was like,
no.
It'll go right through my body and I'll dye.
It depends on how big the stick is.
They're all confident that you gonna to break it.
I guess I don't,
but I've gotten much better.
You'd be fun to be in production with.
You're like,
yeah,
that's a good question.
I'm the worst places when it comes to anything dangerous.
I'm the guy's like,
well listen,
listen.
You'd take chances,
motherfucker.
Okay.
Nothing wrong with that,
but you better be aware of what you're doing.
You know,
don't,
don't be stupid about it.
Take informed chances.
You know,
this,
this season has been a lot of fun,
a lot of fun issue.
Does it,
um,
do you do comedy when you're on the road like filming?
Do you like scheduled gigs and it,
but if I do comedy all of a sudden all the,
all the chaos in my,
all the chaos gets real fucking mellow cause I can talk and I feel like I'm
getting that outlet.
Like I have,
I
was in the middle of like a month stretch from Alaska to New York to DC to
Indianapolis and then leaving Indianapolis.
We had to fly to Cincinnati and my wife's like,
and I'm complaining to her about my brain or whatever.
I'm fucking his role in me.
And then she was like,
just go get on stage.
Just go over to the,
to the funny bone in Cincinnati and get on stage.
It's kind of like I was,
like I said,
this is a good idea
cause it's almost like a form of exercise,
like this x amount of energy that you expend on stage.
Oh yeah.
Like,
like I,
I think I,
one of the things that's wrong with me is I don't,
I don't listen very well and I talk more than I listen.
Like some people are good listeners.
I feel like I'm all fucking exporting data.
Well listen,
you're
where that,
so you,
you'll be a better listener.
It's that simple.
If you're aware of one thing that's fucking with you or one thing that you don't
like about how you behave,
that,
that's step one.
That's me even more than step one,
that step,
step one is like thinking what's wrong with me?
Step two is like figuring out what it is you're at.
Step two,
you already know what it is,
the,
um,
but yeah,
but I think once I do stand up,
uh,
that I start,
I start listening.
So I'm done talking.
Do you ever get done with like a long stretch and you're like,
I'm fucking do not to hear myself speak?
Yes,
sure.
I'm done talking.
I just want,
it's hard to discipline myself to listen to tapes when that happens.
You can fucking listen to tapes.
I've never listened to a tape ever really there.
How do you go over your bits?
It's all my head.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Do you think that that's the best way to do it or you just test the best way for
you?
I,
I know this,
that the best way to do it because anytime I look at a tape,
I go,
man,
I should have fucking,
I can do that different.
And it always works.
But I'm,
I hate looking at myself on film and just watching it and going over it and be
in like,
you know what I say to myself,
but I say,
you're a professional.
I'm a professional comedian and my job as a professional comedian is to do it
the best I can and to do it the best.
I kind of have to review tapes.
I have to actually write,
I have to take chances on stage where I go on stage and I just don't know what
the fuck I'm gonna to talk about.
I just go,
well I have to do that.
Go down dark roads.
Especially like Sal's comedy hall.
I love that place cause it's like ADP bone.
We,
you know,
I can just fuck around and talk about anything and bits will come out of that.
So there's that.
But you got to write and you've got to review your shit.
You gotta to right to it.
You gotta do it all.
You got to do everything I write.
But I think going through my shit,
it's exhausting.
It is exhausting.
But that's part of the job.
You know,
as a,
as I've gotten older and as I've gotten,
I think,
um,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't say that I'd take my standup more seriously,
but I think I've gotten better at being disciplined about it.
Especially like the last special that I did was like,
came out less than a year,
like a little over a year ago.
And I've got a completely new hour and 20 minutes between now and then.
And it was difficult to do that.
I've never done that before.
I always sort of slowly built up an act,
you know,
over the next few years because I kind of had to,
but now the way I do it,
I,
I just,
you know,
and I,
I kinda like got inspired by Louis CK talking about how he comes up with a new
hour every year.
So I,
you know,
I just tried to attack it and write as much as possible and in doing that and
trying to put together a new hour in a year,
you,
you have to review material,
you have to be more disciplined about it.
You have to be more professional about it.
You have it.
I know it's your new,
our thematic of who you are at right now.
It's the best thing I've ever done.
For sure.
It's most the most silly.
But I also think that's part of the reason is because of this podcast.
Like I don't feel like the need to,
um,
extrapolate or,
or to expand on like philosophical ideas or,
or,
or try to make something funny that might not necessarily be fine.
Like all I'm really concerned about as being funny as opposed to,
you know,
like sometimes I'd have bits about something I just wanted to talk about.
Why don't I have to worry about that now because I just talk about it on the
podcast.
You know what I mean?
There's the outlet is better.
So in a sense,
I think it's condensed my comedy and made it,
made it sharper and better.
Made it more funny.
But companies all over the fucking place right now,
everything's all over the place.
What it is your,
uh,
open,
what are your comedy?
What is the d?
Is it any kind of theme or are you just pretty much sound like some guy at the
fucking hotel?
What do you do,
comedian?
So what do you do when you're on stage there?
Do you have a theme to your act,
their fellow?
What's a kind of comedy or do I go about your comedy,
Joe?
You'd say it's more like a storytelling based.
It's kind of conspiracy kind of theory.
You're kind of life,
you know,
you used to be mark conspiracy,
but not,
not really gonna disappear.
So we were talking about like the pyramids.
But you mean to say that it's a conspiracy pyramids,
Noah's Ark,
all that stuff.
But uh,
did,
did you have more of a,
like,
like Betty,
are you more jokey joke?
I'm straight up storytelling.
Storytelling.
I would say.
I would say more so.
I,
my stand up shows more like you're going to watch someone,
you're going,
I feel like it's,
it's literally you're coming to my house.
I'm telling you stories.
I'm standing on the Ottoman and you're sitting on the couch and I'm just,
you're like,
man,
that guy's house.
It's fun to be at like,
it's a lot of just crowd interaction.
You know,
I told you this last time I bring people on stage,
but it was straight up stories.
I've had always had a hard time.
Like I have a great story about the first time I met will Smith and I've had a
hard time.
Um,
I have a hard time telling it because I feel like it's,
I feel like it's,
yeah,
it just,
whenever you,
you're,
you're running uphill whenever you say,
Oh,
here's a time I met wall smelling.
Yeah.
Get the fuck out of here just to hang out with.
I think you,
I think you need to,
uh,
you know,
you have to have a champion fucking store.
If you want to bring up the time you met Wilson Smith just to overcome the
weight of carrying that story around.
But it's,
uh,
but it's all storytelling.
It's,
and it's,
you know,
do you write,
do you sit down and write stuff?
I can't write a story because then it loses the story always works the first
time I tell it on stage and fire ever could've ever videotaped it.
I'd be like,
damn,
that's how I need to tell it every time.
But you got of almost the way I work is my brain.
I've got to feel the beats,
like feel the beats and where they go and where they drop and where they hit.
Right.
And then,
um,
and,
and if I write it,
it just becomes very long winded.
And all the jokes that,
uh,
that,
that would fit in on stage just don't fit it there.
They're like longer themes.
So everything,
everything
you talk about on stage is pretty much stories.
Yeah,
I would say.
So.
You never sit down
with a laptop,
laptop and say,
know I'm going to do the Russian mob story,
then I'm going to do the book for me to tell on stage.
I've done it.
Did it on,
do you ever done Elliot in the morning in DC?
No,
I did early in the morning and I told her that on his show.
And then everyone would come to show and be like machine machine and then I'd
get up at the end of the night and I'd be like,
fuck,
I got to tell the story.
That seems like a show or a story.
Rather you can tell on stage.
I'm gonna try,
I'm gonna try to start working it into shows.
But it's also weird if like,
like I do the f I fight,
do the fight and a bear story on stage.
I do the story about my daughters,
my daughters.
Um,
but yeah,
like she never like say say what if you did a special,
like you're going to do a comedy central special and done an hour.
He did an hour.
When did you do this?
Probably 18 months ago.
And when you did it,
did you feel like you have to write on new stuff after you did it?
Yeah,
but that's,
but I also get,
I feel like a hack.
If I tell old jokes,
I'm very,
I don't like listening.
I feel like a phony a lot,
a lot.
I feel like a phony only because I don't like,
I guess when I,
when I scan in the standup,
I traded whatever,
my wife goes nuts about it.
I traded whatever brain I have that is the guy that gets a job at dean witter or
whatever and has those lunch in stories and tells a story about golf.
Last week I traded him for,
every story is fucking funny.
Every story is funny and like,
and I don't like,
I,
I'm fucking willing to mind anything.
And,
and if,
if it takes it quick,
like the rush of my story,
I obviously shorten a massive chunk of that cause the real story's a little
depressing.
The real story.
He gets really depressing.
So I,
but I,
if you tell it to people,
then they fucking just something crazy about you robbing people.
Do you tell the story about you working out in the bookstore on dude,
you got to tell that one.
I was thinking about that.
What if they,
you never masturbated down there.
There was a guy,
there was a sign up,
this is going to sound even crazier.
It,
there was a signup and I,
when I was,
when you'd go to hidden the freight elevator that said,
whoever there was double doors,
whoever's urinating on the store,
there's officers on the other side.
So I kept seeing that going,
wow,
that's so funny.
I bring the freight elevator down here to work out.
I wonder who's bringing it down to piss on these doors.
And then I started thinking,
what happens when you piss on these doors?
Like does it,
it's got to be a fucking really good payoff for the fo,
for,
for someone to really risk at every month and just do it.
And I was like,
I should do that.
I should definitely pass on those doors.
And then that's why I got caught because they were reviewing tape to find out
who's busy on the doors.
And then they saw me working out and they were like,
well,
it's gotta be him pissed too.
So I'm sure it got fucking for both of those.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
But you know,
it's so funny,
like now that you,
this way my brain works.
I remember tell telling me I had a joke one time about,
um,
uh,
my name is,
when I was growing up,
I tried tagging in my neighborhood,
so I got a can of spray paint and I was all she,
so I was like,
son of a bitch.
I'm the only birth that lives in this neighborhood.
And then I was like,
Sucks Dick.
And it tells like,
that's a great joke.
And I was like,
and as soon as he said that,
I'm like,
that's in every fucking act.
So now that you say you should tell the working out in the Barnes and noble,
as soon as you said that,
my brain went,
oh,
that is good.
I never saw it as good and I never felt worthy and bring on stage.
I laughed when you said that,
you know we have cameras down here too.
That would crush.
Yeah.
Now I'll tell him,
but that's the way my brain works.
Like I had never thought about telling Tracy Morgan and Jay's like,
you've got gotta fucking tell it on stage.
And I was like,
ah.
How did you guys resolve that?
I don't know.
I think so.
I mean,
here's the thing is that if he wants to tell,
you can tell it.
I don't want to tell it.
I don't like this.
Do you make him say that?
Because I don't want Tracy Morgan fucking Tracy one day.
That fucking hen is coming back to roost.
It's going to get mad at you.
Come on.
He's going to love you.
That look,
first of all,
he tells crazier stories and that every time he goes on the radio,
he pulls his shirt off and goes,
so we'll get pregnant.
Oh,
Tracy.
Morgan's one of the most hilarious individuals around,
but I just don't know.
So I don't want to like only met them one time,
so I don't want to,
yeah,
but it's such a funny story.
I don't think he,
I think he's as a comic would just stick out.
That is a hilarious dinner in a weird way.
Also though,
and I,
and I think I've admitted this to Jay.
It's better.
I enjoy the people coming to me and go,
I heard that Tracy Morgan story,
yours as fucking hilarious.
I enjoy that more than telling it every night on stage and having that to be my
closer.
And then every night everyone's like Tracy Morgan.
And I'm like,
oh,
fucking again.
Why?
It's a great story.
I Dunno.
Um,
that's an amazing story.
It's a great story.
Great Story.
And I guarantee you,
I guarantee you Tracy Morgan would have no problem with you.
Tell him that.
Well,
Tracy Morgan is like Joey Diaz,
except every now and then Joey Diaz will get upset.
Do you tell him the truth about some stories about marijuana?
Yeah.
How about the thing?
The other day?
Yeah.
You're telling everybody on your podcasts.
I didn't fucking show up for that.
Show that at one time,
but he didn't tell them I was over at any Bravo's I was at Eddie Bravo.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Yeah.
I like,
I like that response.
He was that Eddie Brown was and then went to go see a movie.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
Meanwhile,
people,
people quote it on my website.
I ain't gonna lie to your dog.
I never left Vegas.
Precious split.
He was in work.
Did you ever do impression you're really good at doing?
People will impression well,
if it's so subtle,
but it really sounds like Brian Gallon.
I can do a few.
I can do it.
Yours jars.
Ooh.
Oh,
I can't,
I can't really do Ari.
I have to know.
I can do people like I can do.
Um,
what do I do?
I can do a Alex Jones.
I could do him real good.
I could get you to do a good Alex Jones lighting gentleman.
Black helicopters have been spotted outside of Dallas,
Texas right now.
We're going to go live info wars.com.
That one enjoyed his or get too.
Those are my two best I can do Mike Tyson actually was,
that's easy.
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Pretty uneasy.
I can do.
I can do Scotty Jay from boogie nights.
Do you remember Boogie Nights?
Your fucking was Philip Seymour Hoffman?
Yes.
Do you remember when this is the only,
it's not even words.
Do you remember when everyone saw Dirk Diggler his cock for the first time?
Yeah.
Everyone had their moment.
Uh,
Burt Reynolds Kinda who's smoking a cigar and kind of went like this.
Everyone kind of went like this and this is Scotty Jay.
This is yet,
he was holding a boom Mike and he just went.
That's the only impression.
Like it's pretty good,
dude.
I think you nailed it back to,
I love that movie.
You know,
when I was a,
when I first started out,
I used to do impressions,
but I stopped doing it because I felt like it was cheap.
It was cheap laughs cause I would see guys that would go on stage and then we'd
get labs just with impressions.
Meanwhile,
there's nothing wrong with dad.
I mean it's kind of interesting to see someone doing an impression.
It like gives you like some sort of a charge.
Like wow,
I sound just like them all.
I was like,
I need four or five of those in my act just to like sprinkle them in between.
There was such a great lake DC to
pull out a fucking,
it is my impression of,
uh,
of a,
of a Italian eye doctor.
What you looking at like,
and it was just like real quick
Benny.
Wow.
I haven't thought about that.
That's,
I haven't seen that guy in forever.
I used to party with him and Ben Bailey and Tony Woods back when I was Tony
Woods.
Tony was just like one of my best friend Johnny Woods.
It's fucking hilarious how he was amazing.
I've never had.
He's like,
um,
I mean I think Dave Chappelle's a very original,
don't get me wrong,
but Tony Woods is like,
their original Dave Chappelle like is very similar style to date and really
fucking funny.
And I'm not saying that Dave stole from him.
David's just a,
it's like he's a,
he's one of those guys that we've all known guys like that for whatever reasons.
Like they're really funny,
but this fucking thing doesn't get on the right track and something doesn't
happen and people don't know.
You're really funny.
You know,
this is a few guys like that word like JB smooth,
you know,
JB Smoove second,
a lot of money to,
there's strong,
he's always been a destroyer man.
I was in,
um,
I did a Gig in New Jersey once with JB smooth and uh,
he was late.
We bought were late,
we got lost.
It was ridiculous directions.
This is pre navigation systems.
Okay.
This is like 1992 91 and we're both pretty much scrubs and a,
you know,
we're both starting out and we're doing these stupid gigs.
And I did this college and they were all excited to see me because I had done
the Naca thing and you get on stage and I killed it,
the Naca Conference,
I can all these bookings and I was so excited while I get there.
I think I've told this story before,
so I'll make it briefly.
Um,
I get there and well the open,
here's not here,
JB Smoove supposed to open.
I was supposed to close.
The opener is not here yet.
So do you want to just sit down and watch TV?
Okay.
So I sit down in their little rec room and watch TV and I watched this fucking
special on the Malibu fires.
I don't know what year it was.
I'm assuming like 93 92 93 and it was devastating.
These people were crying and there was a kid walking around calling out for his
dog and he's walking over these burnt down foundations with smoke coming out and
they're like calling every five seconds.
Mike,
Mikey,
Mikey calling out for the whatever the fuck the dog's name is.
And there's a guy who was a fireman and he's crying.
And he's crying.
Talking about this house was the only thing that,
you know,
he worked his whole life to build this fucking house.
Well the opener hasn't come so we're just going to throw you up.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
And I didn't know back then,
like there's,
I had to learn a bunch of times that you have to get yourself into a certain
state of mind before you go on stage that you can't just,
just try to perform,
you know,
you,
you have to put your mom,
I,
you know,
when you're 21 and no one or whatever the fuck I was and no one's telling you
what to do,
you can kind of develop like,
like really loose habits when it come to your,
your standup.
So I went up there,
dude,
and you know,
I did not know how to start the show off.
I didn't expect to be starting to show up.
So I didn't prepare for that.
I prepared to be following the guy so I didn't have anything.
I didn't know.
You know,
when you start a show off from scratch,
you've got to settle everybody in.
You've got to calm way down,
get control of the room,
then start with some jokes and open,
strong,
open,
so that they think it's worth following you and paying attention.
I did neither of these things.
All I did was go on stage and think about these poor fucking people that lost
their houses to the fire.
So then for whatever reason,
a joke,
bombs,
right?
And then I just say,
I shouldn't watch that fucking show.
I'm sorry.
This is what I did.
I right before I went onstage,
I watched his documentary about all these people in Malibu who lost their houses
to fires.
And I'll go and I'm fucking depressed.
And the,
you know,
the audience is like 200 kids.
They're like,
what are you,
why are you telling us this?
Are you a fucking comedian?
Like what do you mean?
Yeah,
it was terrible.
And then JB smooth finally showed up.
So he goes on after I eat dick for half an hour,
he goes up and just crushes.
And it was exactly what they want.
He was silly and high energy and you know,
he just picked up the ball where I left it in a pilot dog shit and just ran with
it and,
but he's another guy.
It's like,
why is that guy not a giant fucking huge star.
Tony was probably any problem.
Imagine you've never seen him do stand up anyway.
He used to go on and purposely literally not speak for the first two minutes and
just totally woods would not speak and just get himself organized,
real slow delivery and then he'd say something like,
I know what you're thinking.
A joke would be good right about now,
but I'm black and I don't when I don't,
just when I get to work doesn't mean I started working.
I got to walk around for 15 minutes and see who to go.
He was so fucking,
he was like my zen master when I started comedy,
like just really fucking like just,
Oh like I'd tell a story and be like,
that story is good.
I told a story one night about fucking old girl on the wait staff that worked at
the Boston comedy club and I lasted like two seconds and she got really fucking
pissed.
Started yelling at me after and I was like,
I was,
and I didn't give a shit.
I'm just fucking drunk and where my hotel room.
And I was like,
listen,
you can't do that shit.
I was telling them on stage,
I was like,
you can't do that shit.
And she was like,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
You better go online,
learn how to read a manual about how to fuck somebody.
And I was like,
I was like,
you know what,
I don't care.
I got,
I fucked you.
I went and she was like,
Ahhh.
And then I go and you're getting out of here,
you're going to Brooklyn.
And so she was like,
mother fucker and then got all dress got or I still am totally naked with a beer
in my hand.
She's at my door.
And she was like,
she was like,
I swear to God fucked.
And then looked at me and went like that and I went.
And then we both started laughing.
I slammed the door and then she pounded on every door in my building going,
Burke Chrysler,
can't fuck for Christ again.
It's true.
Is it true story?
Yeah.
And so I get done and I thought,
I told him on stage and then I get off and Tony Woods goes,
all right,
number one,
don't ever tell that story ever again.
I go,
why not?
And he goes,
no one wants to hear that shit.
All right,
let's leave.
Tony was just like the best to be around.
Why?
Well,
he's wrong.
I want to hear that story.
No,
no,
no.
He's looked in DC.
I give him a quiet time.
Why would he,
why would he say not to tell that story?
Because you don't want people to know that you can't fuck.
Uh,
and that's a black white thing.
Black guys.
No.
I want to talk about how bad the iron bed,
but yeah,
there's a lot of things that are different.
I remember we did a show with Danelle Rollins and red grant with two black
comics and they were like,
Oh man,
you never run a train on nobody.
No,
I've never run a trailer on anybody.
And they're like,
oh man,
that must just be a hood thing.
And I was like,
what you guys like,
like fuck a girl at the same time?
And then he's like,
yeah,
he brother down,
everyone ran trains on people.
I was like,
I've never once ran a train.
I go,
that's kind of gay.
And like,
no.
And I was lucky at all like a bunch of guys like playing leaky submarine with
some girl just log,
log,
log.
There's a whole back here.
But uh,
and but that's another thing that I don't think dance has nothing to do with
brothers.
That's just freaks.
Serious warning hanging out with,
and I guarantee you two to trend topic,
who run trains,
dude,
people run trains and all racists really have you run the train.
Listen,
we're on the Internet right now.
I've never got time to time.
How many people can you guess how many people you've had sex with?
Yeah.
Really.
I've got like eight,
eight.
That's it.
It's good.
You're doing well.
My wife,
was it seven more than I expected for it.
I'll say good after that way.
Just you just called it quits,
but then I remembered you had a daughter.
I Dunno man.
I stopped counting.
When your,
when your comic and you're on the road,
things get squirrely and you're a single man.
He can do whatever you want.
Oh,
things can get squirrely.
Oh my God.
How many comics do you know that would literally debts what they were looking
for more than even doing comedy.
They just want to get laid after shows.
Oh,
every single one.
We know a lot of guys,
I know guys,
they've damaged their careers because they don't,
right?
They don't do anything.
All they do is just try to go up and sit on stage and kill and hope they me to
grow after the show.
That was the,
that my county,
that was the way I,
I,
I wrapped my head around the store.
Really?
I thought the store was all like fucking Ahmed.
Sebastian,
Steve,
Brett.
I thought Mike Young.
I thought they all just went up murdered just to fuck and then I was like,
do you think they did it?
Do you think that that's like a,
is that a valid thought or does that just weird paranoia?
I think
I did a tour with those guys was and they were just like,
they're like,
I was doing more time.
You're like what the fuck are you doing?
Like we were to doing like 20 minutes
and I was doing 30 all right,
what do you do in 34 let's get outta here.
And I was like a bar bar,
let's fucking party.
I was like,
I'm married,
I want to do time.
That's funny.
I wanted to do extra stand out and they wanted to get off quicker so that
they're worried about,
see if there's Mike Young Brent,
Ernst and Aaron was Aaron cater all in one room and then you know you,
you want to be the first guy offstage cause we want to be the one to attack
quick.
You don't want to get there after Mike Young has already taken her into the
bathroom.
Yeah,
it could be careful.
I'll get Mike,
Mike,
his middle name is it.
Mike isn't young anymore.
That's how it should be.
He's like crazy men to does he?
Oh yeah,
he's got that pancreas pancreatic cancer in his family.
What's that?
Yeah,
he's got cancer,
brain cancer or pancreatic cysts.
So you've,
you ever eat with them?
Eat with them?
What does he eat?
He just eats very healthy.
Like we went to Hooters one day and he had a chicken breast and had a bowl of
lettuce and I was like,
what?
And he was like,
man,
I gotta keep my healthy,
my shit.
Clean cancer runs in my family and it creeps up and you die.
Wow.
Yeah.
Like he doesn't drink beers.
We'll do shots of Tequila.
That's healthy.
That's real good for you.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Is that who Joey Diaz has started smoking cigarettes again?
What?
Yeah,
what does he doing?
Wait,
how I saw him smoking.
He didn't just start,
it's been going on for a while.
I smoke them one at the airport the other day.
He was telling him for a while he was telling me that he only smokes and before
shows.
But then I saw him smoking while at the airport.
What's going on?
He's awesome.
How old's Joey Diaz in a Joey Diaz.
It's like bigfoot.
No,
when,
when he dies there will be no,
no record of him.
Who Do you want to be at your funeral?
No one.
No one light me on fire.
Who gives a fuck?
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Stupid.
I don't want a bunch of people standing around crying cause I'm gone.
I don't like,
I don't want to,
yeah,
I don't like going to them.
I hate funerals.
I've skipped like the last three.
I scraped that died.
My friends or friends die.
I,
you know,
I'm more than them in my own mind and think about them,
but I'm not into it.
So when did he start smoking?
Because I see him the other day with a cigarette.
I go,
what the fuck is going on?
Well,
you know what I found out,
Brian,
did you tell me or did already tell me?
Ari told me a Joey's outside small again.
And I go,
did we just smoked?
I thought he meant we'd,
he goes,
no,
no smoking that other stuff.
I got other stuff.
Yeah.
And then we were working in Braille and then I went outside and Joey smoking a
cigarette with you and like,
what are you doing?
It's just gets the fucking party started.
Let's get the blood pumping.
You know what I'm saying?
My,
before I go on stage,
I go,
you smoking cigarettes,
get na na na,
right before I go up my,
before I go up,
I should get a little taste.
Get a little fucking makes me crazy.
It makes me nuts.
I just want to go up there and got fucking nuts on these mother fuckers.
It's been a while actually.
I've known about it for maybe a year.
Oh,
just Terry still smoked as his girl.
So small.
I don't think she does,
but she did last time I saw her.
She did last time you saw her,
which was how long ago?
Well why go at all the drunk cast?
The UFC drunk cast.
I don't like people dabble in cigarettes match.
Scary thing.
Joe.
We had a on a res,
uh,
podcast yesterday on death squad.
Uh,
we
had,
uh,
Macklin Mac Lindsey and he was,
I don't know if you saw it now,
but he was talking about how he,
you know,
grew up being a huge drug addict,
homeless,
you know,
meth head and he did like Doug Stan hope show while he was on meth.
And then I dug like when talk to him for five years and it's a pretty
interesting interview,
but the one thing he says like,
he's like,
you know,
everything else I haven't touched anything for five years and everything but
fucking cigarettes,
I can't fucking do it.
He's like,
I've tried so many times and he's like,
it's impossible.
He's like,
I'll quit.
And it's just amazing how,
I mean math even.
Yeah.
That's why I'm like looking at Joe and I'm like,
what makes you think you had a real hard time for years?
He would tell me,
Joe Rogan this the hardest fucking thing.
I have adequate those cigarettes.
There's something in them to get in your bones.
You know what I'm saying?
Amber League and you'll fucking sweat your blood.
They get in there and you can't get them out.
Joe Rogan,
it can't get them out and now I see it.
I see someone smoking.
It makes me sick.
It makes me sick to my stomach.
I can't believe I ever did that.
So to see him smoking again after all of that.
Even though you say that in which is what I would say too,
when I quit.
Yeah,
it's in the back of your head though.
Every time he smell it or see a cigarette,
you still think
I still think about it.
I haven't spoken in,
I would spoke to him.
Oh well over 20 years.
What does it make you feel like?
What?
What you what?
What is the feeling?
Why?
Because no one see when when you smoke pot you sit back and you're like,
whoa.
Like you feel it hit you.
It's instant.
It changes your outlook.
It gives you an altered perception.
It's like it changes your body,
it makes you more sensitive.
I see people smoking cigarettes and I'm like,
you're still the same guy.
Like he's nothing like relax as you relax you tobacco for a long time now for
the same reason.
Yeah,
to tobacco because like,
I couldn't imagine doing this,
what we're doing right now without a dip in my mouth.
Really.
I couldn't imagine.
I could not imagine if you,
if you,
someone would come in to like our lounge and our fraternity or,
or into my apartment.
I'd be like,
dude,
you're never gonna believe what happened.
I'd be like,
gimme a second.
Let me get a dip.
Because a good story was like,
you had to have a depth first.
All man south from sales calming.
I was addicted to cigars.
Holy Shit.
That guy is just,
I go,
how many do you smoke a day?
He's like all day,
like all day.
And he smoked them when they're like,
just a blob and then he goes and crap.
Give somebody money to go buy a more.
Cause he does.
He inhaled them.
No,
you don't inhale cigars.
People do.
Really?
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
Usually people that are addicted to cigars and nailed them.
Yeah.
Most people that are addicted to cigars.
I smoke cigars.
I don't inhale them,
so I,
if I have one,
it's going to be because my dad's in town where someone says,
hey,
would anyone like a cigar?
Like I don't do.
Do you want to come with me?
Man,
I got a membership at the Grand Havana Room.
I got a human door up there and everything serious.
You don't smoke cigars,
do they?
I mean my a friend Matt,
we go there every now and then.
We a little butt buddies where our names on the plaque together.
We share a box.
We got a bunch of Cuban cigars.
The shills.
Yeah,
you sit down and feel like a fat cat.
You know,
it was all these assholes.
But what's really interesting is how many like celebrities go there.
Like you see like look,
it's David Caruso who looks a million years old by the way.
That's like,
wow,
that was the guy.
That's the guy from Nyp d balloon now.
Now he's become this weird sort of a caricature with,
you know this his
sunglasses and that.
The CSI Miami,
those shows,
man,
you doing one of those shows,
you want to talk about a life changing thing that's your new life pal.
You're new,
your new life.
It revolves around this show that you're doing because you're going to film it
most of the year and you're going to film it most of the day,
most of the week,
almost the entire week.
You're going to be spent filming five,
six days a week,
12 hour days,
sometimes more depending on which shots need to get done.
Those,
those fucking shows are Baroud All.
I've had a bunch of offers.
I've had a few things come my way where you know they wanted to meet me for
something like that.
I'm like,
what is it?
Single camera dramas.
Stop,
stop talking,
stop talking to me.
I'm not doing,
it.
Don't seem like a five year plan,
five year plan.
The more time goes on,
man,
the more I am just enjoying doing comedy,
doing the podcast and doing the UFC and I wished the UFC.
I would like to do less of those.
I love doing it,
but sometimes I traveled,
uh,
just a bit too much.
I would love it if it was like in la or something like that,
but sometimes it's hard,
but when I'm there,
I never wish I was anywhere else.
It's,
I will,
I'm enjoying everything I do.
So I'm very careful right now to make sure that I don't take on anything else
that I don't enjoy.
Because right now my life is like a little masterpiece.
Like I've got it set up.
So I'm like,
when I'm in town,
I'm enjoying everything I'm doing.
I have the greatest group of friends,
you know,
and a part of it is this podcast,
and now because of this podcast,
the people that are coming to see me at the shows are different.
It's like now they're all podcast fans and they really know where the fuck I'm
coming from.
And we're all,
we're,
we're all coming from.
I mean,
Brian gets fucking huge rounds of applause when he goes on stage.
Now Brian do like five minutes sets and in Portland's gets huge round of
applause.
Ari does two huge,
huge round of applause in Seattle as the puff daddy of podcasts.
Bollen Bro.
But it's,
you know,
it's all good stuff.
It's not like when I was doing fear factor,
it was like,
it was a great job.
It was,
you know,
it paid ridiculous money and it was really easy.
It was three days a week,
but during those three days,
I would wish I was doing something else and I did it,
you know,
happily,
cause it was a lot of money.
But there's never a time when I'm doing a podcast.
Never a time when I'm doing standup.
Never a time when I'm doing the UFC where I go,
wow,
I wish I was doing something else.
Every time this UFC,
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
here we go.
You know the,
the bone bone,
the sound comes on the lights.
Dim first fight starts.
I'm like,
Woah.
Punched knuckles with Mike Goldberg here would go every time.
Man.
I'm like a little kid.
I love it.
I just never a time when I'm like,
God can't.
I'm sitting here watching fights,
never,
never.
And to stand up right before I'm going to go on stage.
There's never a time where I'm like,
fuck,
I can't believe I'm doing standup.
Never.
No.
I know.
How,
um,
how much,
how much does money,
um,
incorporating to any of your decision making?
Well,
yeah,
it has to,
you know,
but luckily I make good money from the UFC and I make good money from stand up
so it doesn't have to,
it's like long as those things are covered,
then I don't have to think about it.
It's when they're not covered,
then it has to become an issue.
Like say okay,
go ahead.
Like I say,
when I first started doing fear factor,
I was not making really good money with standup.
I was doing news radio the same time.
Can you tell me how much you're making one stand up back then?
A few grand a week.
A couple grand,
a couple grand or two grand.
2,500 maybe on a good week.
But I was doing like Thursday through Sunday,
you know,
maybe news radio was getting,
it was a little more than that towards the end because it was 99 when I put out
my CD and that,
that definitely helped.
And I was getting paid better and clubs and there was some places where I could
sell out,
but there was inconsistent and it's few and far between.
So like when something like fear factor came up,
it was like,
well here's a good chance to make really good money.
You know?
And when you say like 2,500 people go,
wow,
that's a lot of money.
But then you know when you take away agent's fees,
manager manager's fees and also business manager
and consider your own tax and taxes radio.
Yeah,
I,
I can tell you exactly how much you walk away with 2,500 that was my rate.
Yeah.
You walk away with 30 cents on the dollar,
25 cents on the dollar.
So yeah,
it's ridiculous.
But that's just the way it is.
So you have to make good money to stay ahead of the curve.
And then if you want to be able to relax,
you have to have enough in the bank so you don't worry if something happens.
You,
you want financial freedom.
The real financial freedom is not,
it's not the freedom to,
you know,
to buy things and to own things.
The real financial freedom is to not worry about money.
That's,
that's the number one thing.
Get yourself in a place where you could feed yourself and,
and,
and be able to,
Brian counts at this to me once and I really took it to heart and he goes,
I,
it was being rich.
I'd like to be right.
Yeah.
But I don't want,
I want to do,
so I don't people to Google a nice restaurant whenever I want,
go to a nice restaurant.
And I'm like,
that's so true.
Like be able to eat at a nice place and never go,
well,
how much is the stake?
28 how much is the fish?
24 fish fish.
You know that feeling,
which means,
you know,
I mean,
I clearly remember thinking like that,
you know,
that's,
that's real financial freedom and you don't have to think about stuff.
So the way I've got everything set up man,
it's like I'm in a real good spot right now.
So I gotta be real careful about taking on any other things I talked about.
I'm pitching this show right now.
It's sort of a based on some of the ideas that came up on the podcast,
but the really,
the more I'm thinking about it,
the more I'd rather just put cameras on the podcast,
the most ideal thing because we were pretty much doing it already.
Might as well do it.
Do it not like this in your career.
I would say this is probably the most,
and this is,
this is just as a person who's,
who's obviously bit of a fan of yours and I TIF a friend somewhat,
but uh,
this is probably the most representative of you and this is,
this is your,
this is the one thing that I think when you pass,
people will go do his podcast was fucking,
that was before people were really,
they could be doing them and,
and it was just,
it was breaking ground.
I mean it was like,
and it was his,
it's your personality will stand up to your personality,
but it also has to be,
uh,
delivered in a one to set,
there is a payoff in every moment your stand up.
So you will compromise despite how much people will argue this.
You will compromise your voice for a joke.
A lot of times,
yes,
it's different and I don't feel like I have to get my voice out anymore.
You know,
I used to feel like there were certain things that I wanted to say on stage that
maybe I couldn't say it because I couldn't condense it into a joke form.
I don't feel like that anymore.
You know,
there's a lot of stuff
that I have.
There's a lot of weird thoughts that I have that I've expressed on the podcast
and I've explored in depth that almost have no payoff as far as humor.
You know,
my idea about the whole universe being some complex mathematical problem,
every little thing that goes on,
is it just a part of some giant fucking algorithm?
This is something that I've been dwelling on for a long,
long time.
There's nothing humorous in that,
but we've discussed it on the podcast a bunch of times,
so I totally believe that in parallel states.
Yeah,
I fucking totally believe in that shit.
I believe that.
Did you ever think to yourself like,
I can't believe I'm still alive.
His isn't know
Brian does.
Cause Brian ate onions this morning and it's hard.
Almost fucking heart palpitations.
Brian has this super hot girl too.
Can you tell the story you were telling me right before you started the show
about how lazy you are?
Oh yeah,
sure.
Tell this.
This is,
this is ridiculous.
This motherfucker is first of all this girls dating 10 okay.
10 solid 10 not 10 phase,
but at six personality,
not 10 phase,
but a five body.
She's a fucking 10 she's a 10 La 10 as an ally to legit 10 I don't,
I don't use la tents.
I use tents.
This is,
I don't,
I don't judge anybody in any other way.
This is it.
Straight up across the board.
There's no,
no doubt.
I was just hoping
tired to have sex.
What's wrong with that?
No.
Tell me what you did.
I went down on her gig.
She had orgasms and I was like,
I'm good.
I'm going to bed,
dude.
You need to go to a doctor.
All right.
You need to get some,
get your fucking blood work done.
Find out you need Niacin and your diet and cooperate some squats,
dear.
Get off the cigarettes.
We had sex.
We had,
this is my wife would hate that I'm talking about this.
Don't let her know we have a podcast.
My wife couldn't figure out a fucking computer.
It's broken.
I don't,
and why does it always break when I touch it?
Cause you're a fucking retard.
So she says,
um,
we,
uh,
my whole thing is go oral first and then we'll do Tutsis.
Right?
And so we had oral sex and then she said,
I said,
all right.
And she goes,
well what about just me?
It doesn't matter.
It's so often it's just you.
What am I linked?
Just get the head all the time.
Like,
no,
just to squirt it in there and go to sleep.
You're like,
sorry.
Really?
Do you do that?
You don't say,
do you realize how different we are too?
I enjoy eating pussy.
You have talked about many times.
So today even if I'm not horny and they're Horny,
I'd be like,
oh dude,
I'll totally take care of you.
You don't get horny once you're eating pussy.
Yeah.
That's pretty good.
That's like saying like I,
yeah,
I'll,
I'll go with you and I'll just chew it and spit it on the floor.
I'm going to fucking swallow it.
Brian
RSS feeds.
I'm saying that's what I do every time.
Last night I was so fucking never done that in my life.
Never been too tired to fuck.
I've never done that in my life.
Who tried to drink and I woke up and took care of her.
So,
but Brian did you,
you were not aroused at all.
You were sleep.
Well,
last night I seriously was so fucking bay.
Actually.
I take it back.
I know why.
I did it on top of being so tired.
I was fucking stuff out of my mind.
I made like these huge garlic stakes and vegetables and stuff,
so it was more just kind of like,
you know what?
I just not [inaudible] system is just crawled down to a halt kid.
You know where you're supposed to take a nap,
you know after you eat a big meal,
she wants her box Eaton and she's a 10 yeah.
Yeah.
Meanwhile he falls asleep.
Maybe you could consider looking at it.
She goes,
oh,
he's,
I thank God
I couldn't maybe consider that.
If I had taken an ambien and had one of those sleepwalking episodes and my
wife's like,
you woke up in the middle of night and eat my pussy,
you don't remember that?
And I'm like,
Oh,
must be the ambien.
But I can't imagine just doing that sober.
Do you ever worry,
do you ever worry that she's going to think that you're not attracted to her for
I don't fuck her when?
No,
because normally I wish we were at my house right now so I can just go grab my
trashcan.
We normally fuck like six times a day.
So you have your trashcan.
How do,
wait,
what are you doing with your trash?
I Know God,
Jesus Christ,
the national average is six times a month.
I know.
That's what my normal average is too.
Fucking paraplegics.
She's the one that I'm very lucky because she's one of those girls that you
could just touch her in her arms.
She goes,
oh,
I can like that.
It says she's just fucking nice to you the other day.
Why do I find listening to you?
Fuck talks so distasteful.
There's something about it just,
I'm like,
I'm going like this with my mouth.
She's one of these girls that always grabbed your hand when you're just in the
middle of conversation and she just puts her hand in her pussy and it's just
like juice.
Yeah,
it was those don't exist in my world.
They no,
never.
No.
I've never had any of,
you have a very small like test group.
You're working with people.
She didn't.
I'm target marking out of Iowa was trying to learn how rice krispies cell only
have this one city.
Did you say that your show is um,
targeted,
like that whole network is targeted towards women towards women?
Yes.
Network.
He's on a travel channel,
which by the way,
one of my favorite shows that too.
Two of my favorite shows a Anthony Bourdain's.
No reservations.
I fucking loved that show.
Great show and made it really recommended some great restaurants to me because
of that show.
I found out about a,
a great seafood place.
God,
I can't remember the name in Austin.
It would be great if I could pull the name out of my ass.
But it was a fantastic seafood place in Austin that I found out about.
I found out about places in la found out about a place in La,
a Mexican joint that serves goats.
Okay.
They have giant fucking like sides of goat.
Next song it with a band saw and cooking it all together.
They cook like hundreds of pounds of goat every day.
The amazing,
you know,
I found out about a bunch of great places.
And then also that Steve Rinella shell you said did not get such good writing so
maybe you shouldn't be done.
Yeah,
but it might be done.
Do Amazing.
They're going to bring it back you think?
Oh I doubt it.
Really.
I don't.
I'm,
I'm speculating.
I don't,
why the fuck nothing.
I know.
Dot.
Good fucking show.
It was a good show.
But you know,
here's the thing is that,
you know,
for a first season show you kind of got to hit a home run.
I mean,
cause it's,
you know,
people get just as excited about new projects as they do successes.
They don't get excited for
shows.
It did pretty good.
We'll also,
when you're dealing with a women based network,
man,
it's going to be hard to promote a show about hunting.
I think all,
I think all networks other,
I mean almost all networks really target women.
No,
no,
not at all.
No.
That's my age.
18 to 34 males,
18 to 34 males are where the money is.
That's what they always taught.
Really?
Yeah.
Maybe I got our demographic off,
but I couldn't swear as far as,
I mean obviously you can make a lot of money if you're Oprah,
but as far as like,
you know the,
the people that spend the most,
it's 18 to 34 year old males.
That's the 18 to 49 occasionally,
depending on how far they want to stretch your demographic.
[inaudible] three but I bet I bet unravel and food network and there's a couple
of those all do waving.
I could see that.
Totally.
And Anthony Bordain,
Anthony Bourdain's show is very male centric,
I would think.
You know,
the way he discusses things and talks about things and drinks a lot and he's a
fun fucking show.
Yeah.
But I think,
I think even like a Adam Richmond's vote shows very women love it.
But women like,
I mean I think women will watch a guy,
they,
they want to connect with,
connect with you.
And like,
you know,
that's what I think was a big fear of my show is that I'm kind of a meathead
free.
I'm like Forrest Gump frat boy.
So like who wants to watch a guy scream all over the world and,
and jump and that they underestimated your charm.
Exactly.
That's what I said is,
but the step.
But now that our show is doing good and so,
and you told me this and Richmond guy,
this man versus food,
he got so fucking fat that he doesn't even do the challenges anymore.
I never said that joke.
Oh,
okay.
He didn't say that.
No,
I didn't.
When I heard on the Internet,
see if it wasn't yet.
I'm sorry.
It wasn't,
you know,
what I heard on the Internet was that this guy got so fucking fat that he
doesn't do the challenges anymore.
Is that true?
No.
He know he's not doing the challenges anymore.
That is fuck is that,
I think that's the whole show though.
I think he got fat.
I think you've just fucked his body up.
Well I think it's just a very unhealthy,
it was the reason why I said this is,
there was a thread about it on my message board.
This is a long time ago before I even talked to anybody about it.
And a,
it showed a picture of him from season one to what season is.
He now sees him for poor fuck.
Yeah,
he's,
but he's his body just,
you know,
he does all the cleanses and detoxes and even still,
it was just like,
it was like,
fuck,
it's 30 pound cheeseburgers and shit dude,
I show you can't do that show for six seasons for 20 seasons.
So they had to kind of change it I think to make it more of a sustainable show
for so it could carry on that long.
And so now it's called man versus food nation and they're doing it where he
brings in like they did the nasty boys in Tampa or the Cha.
I maybe I should definitely shouldn't be talking about his show to talk about a
shot bro.
But uh,
but yeah,
let's talk about birth.
The motherfucking conqueror.
Tell these bitches when they can watch it.
When is it on Sunday nights at eight o'clock Sunday nights at eight o'clock I
will now set my DVR.
Bert is a fucking hero.
He's one of my favorite human beings on the planet.
You're a fucking,
you're an awesome dude,
man.
You've got a great laugh.
You've got a great personality.
Your stories of the Shit pretty loud.
Please tell that fucking Barnes and noble story on stage.
It's going to be a crusher dude.
It's a,
and you can do their Russian one to Bert Kreischer.
If you want to follow up on Twitter,
you can follow him.
It is B.
That's a complicated as fucking shirt is cool or something like that.
Can you change your handle,
Burt?
Is Does Shit.
I used to be Joe rogan.net.
It used to be DLT,
any t,
but it was so long.
It was impossible to retweet me.
Like if I said anything funny,
like you would have to like chop it all up because there was too many words.
Like if I tried to use like I used to think like the new Twitter,
you can retweet something and it just retweets it in its entirety.
You're like,
is this a separate hundred 40 characters?
But it used to not be that.
It used to be that when you retweeted something,
you had to account for all the characters inside their name.
You don't have to do that anymore.
No,
no.
You don't have to do it anymore on Twitter.
You just hit retweet it and they can just take care of it the way it is.
So I anyway,
and some dude had Joe Rogan,
he had,
what can I change mine to just do it.
Make sure it's something that's memorable.
You don't have to do your last name like Burt k or pub.
Burt likes to fuck aren't the machine tell your wife about it.
Just all nonchalantly.
Yeah.
Changed my Twitter name to Burt likes to fuck.
What?
What book likes to fuck who?
I just like it in general.
I just like it.
It's awesome.
I don't like it.
What's the awesome awesomest it's the greatest thing you ever,
your fans are ridiculous on Twitter.
I wouldn't,
last time I did this show,
I got like 3000 fans.
Really?
Well we want you to get 3000 more today and you know,
and anytime I told you anytime you ever have a show,
please let me know and I'll tweet it and uh,
we'll pump it up on the podcast.
One of those.
So bad.
You want a flashlight?
I got one for you.
Are you serious?
So awkward to buy one.
Well you don't have to buy one.
I'll give you a free one,
Joe.
Use that one last night and use that one.
I haven't used any of the ones that are laying around.
Hammer.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click the link.
We want to thank,
first of all,
thank the fleshlight for being our sponsor.
It's a cool company and you know,
it's embarrassing for a lot of people and now it's become 10 minutes on my act
right now.
I did a joke,
I was wrong.
I made a joke the other day on stage.
I don't remember the reference,
I don't know how it came out,
but I made a joke about a fleshlight and said,
uh,
I said yeah and then just typing in the Promo Code Rogan and the place went
fucking bananas because there are podcasts,
but it was in Irvine Promo Rogan and they fucking like crazy.
That's hilarious.
Well you said you had a lot of people come up to you and Eric.
Do I have more people come up to me from your show then my TV show.
Wow.
I love it because it's your,
your company fans are like straight up comedy fans.
They don't fucking heckle.
They don't,
they don't like drink too much and get fucking kicked out.
They're just good.
Like just random random,
I told you a girl from HGTV listens to this.
What are the heads of directors of HGTV was like,
I heard you on the Rogan podcasts.
Dtv h g holding card.
Oh I thought you were talking about HD.
That makes sense because that's like the fight network and they were like
straight up like I was like shut.
Oh that's awesome.
Hi to her.
Hey listen,
the best thing about this podcast is that we develop like a real connection with
all these people and it's like,
you know what people tell me is it was,
it's like they're hanging
out with us.
You know what I mean?
Dude,
the best testament to the show,
and I swear this on my children,
when I'm on the road,
I'll put it on the podcast and put it on low in the pillow next to me and just
feel like I'm listening to friends talking to the other room and it puts me to
sleep and I just go and then,
but a lot of times where I had to stop cause I would,
we'd be kicked out and feel weird.
I can't do it to a new one because I'll end up listening to the whole fucking
thing.
Oh,
right through the old reruns.
And it needs to be Ari like someone is you're afraid.
Energy,
like just very like,
and I've listened to the one where you guys say you're our impression,
but the one where you guys had the blackout still.
I listened to that a million times because I love listening to,
I love that he passes out halfway through.
Yeah.
Completely gone.
Well Joey got so tired because he needed a cookie,
any smoke joints and he hit the,
hit the bag.
He had the vaporizer bag too.
He gets so hot,
he goes down a downward spiral.
Joey's the reason why I found out the difference between indicas and sativas
cause I never smoke into kiss.
I really didn't realize that there's was so much of a difference until I smoked
Joey's weed.
Me and Brian and Dunkin were hanging out in Houston,
Texas.
We're in the lobby of the hotel and we were just sitting there slack jawed and
no one was moving.
No one's going anywhere.
And I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with us?
And then,
and then I think it was Dunkin that realized it.
Right?
You guys,
I think we just smoked Joey's.
We'd know.
What have we done cause jelly.
Just like,
I just like to get blessed a dog.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Oh Gee coach,
what do you got?
Bad third I train wreck.
Come with bitches,
come wedded.
He'll,
he'll just,
whatever the fuck you got man.
He'll smoke it,
but he,
he used to be on,
he doesn't do it anymore.
Now he likes hybrids,
which are good because hybrids that give you like that heavy thing but it also
relaxes you.
Good.
Good for comedy.
When I fucking,
whenever I get the chance to have a regular life or maybe I'll take off,
we'd spoken then,
but I can't do it.
No fucking all over it.
You could dude,
look,
we're going to get you what kind of an isolation tank.
We're going to get you some exercise videos to follow.
We are going to rebuild.
Bert Kreischer thank you to the flashlight for sponsoring our show.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click in the code name Rogan.
You get 15% off.
Folks who are interested in coming to see me in Toronto,
there's a very few tickets left.
They're almost out.
And the only way you can get them now,
ticket hall Ticketmaster's sold out.
But if you go to my Twitter,
there's a,
there's a link for the Massey Hall is where I'm playing and they have uh,
they have tickets available on their website,
but that's it.
And I can't fucking wait.
It's going to be awesome.
I can't wait to go there.
Thank you.
Everybody that came to Portland,
Portland was the shit.
One of my new favorite towns.
Everyone fucking awesome.
Nice these people.
Everybody was super cool and like I said,
never been handed more.
We'd ever in my life after shows,
it was really,
I felt bad.
I had to take your weed.
I can't take this.
I have too much.
I can't bring it home with me.
Um,
Philly,
Philly is all sold out.
I believe we put in a second shelf Thursday night and that might be the only
thing that's there.
There's tickets left.
So that's helium and Philly,
which next weekend.
And that's with Joey and Ari.
It's the full death squad pitches.
Brian would dub has cows having her birthday and he has to eat her box.
Wow.
Well,
um,
so um,
so that's it folks.
And we'll see you Thursday and a Friday is going to be a Kevin from attack of
the show.
Really special.
Yeah.
Especially Friday episode.
The Guy,
I'm not,
it's separate prayer.
Prayer.
How do you pronounce his last name?
Kevin.
That guy.
He's very cool.
I've known him many times and I never,
I don't forget how to,
we'll figure it out.
We're gonna get to the bottom of this and that'd be Friday if three and somebody
else on Thursday.
I'm not sure.
Maybe Steven is easy if he's home.
Oh right pitches.
You know,
I love you.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
Thank you very much for coming out to all the shows and for everything you do
and for being a part of this fucking crazy experience.
We're all going through together.
Burke crashes in the motherfucking house.
Ladies,
John Bark cry.
Thank you Burt.
Appreciate it,
brother.
Thank you,
Joe.
Thank you.
Brian.
Subscribed,
subscribing desk squad.
Watch my show this Sunday.
Yeah,
watch bird.
You so please.
Okay.